THIS WILL BEGIN TODAY'S SOMEONE
HEARING ON APRIL EIGHTEENTH OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN I'D LIKE TO
INVITE THE FIRST PANEL UP FOR
ISSUE ONE
.
WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON. DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
LET A STOUT THE DIRECTOR THE
APARTMENT COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT.
AS WELL AS ADJACENT WEMBLEY THE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
FIFTY ADMINISTERS FUNDING THAT'S
PROVIDED TO THE COMMUNITY ACTION
AGENCIES NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR
PROGRAMS INTENDED TO REDUCE
POVERTY AND IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
THE DEPARTMENT RECEIVES FEDERAL
FUNDING FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES FOR
THE COMMUNITY SERVICES BLOCK
GRANT AND THE LOW INCOME HOME
ENERGY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
THE NETWORK OF AGENCIES USE THE
COMMUNITY SERVICES BLOCK GRANT
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT. FOR THOSE
LIVING IN POVERTY THROUGH AN
ARRAY OF SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
BASED ON THE NEEDS OF THE LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES THAT THEY
SERVE.
THESE MAY INCLUDE JOB TRAINING
EDUCATION HEAD START IN
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS.
VOLUNTEER TAX INCOME TAX
ASSISTANCE.
TRANSPORTATION VOUCHERS FOOD
BANKS AND HOMELESS A ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM SUCH AS RAIL VOUCHERS
SHELTERS. AND TRANSITIONAL
ASSISTANCE TRANSITIONAL LIVING
ASSISTANCE.
EACH YEAR THESE AGENCIES SERVE
ABOUT ONE POINT NINE MILLION LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
THROUGH EFFECTIVE STRATEGIES FOR
EVERYONE DOLLAR OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES BLOCK GRANT FUNDING
CALIFORNIA'S NETWORK OF AGENCIES
LEVERAGE ON AVERAGE TWENTY EIGHT
DOLLARS.
FROM FEDERAL STATE. LOCAL AND
PRIVATE SOURCES
AND THIS OFTEN INCLUDES THE
VALUE OF VOLUNTEER SERVICES.
THESE AGENCIES PROVIDE A
TREMENDOUS SERVICE AND
SUBSTANTIAL BENEFITS ALONE TO
THOSE LIVING IN POVERTY.
IN FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED.
A TWO AND HALF MILLION DOLLARS
OF COMMUNITY SERVICE BLOCK GRANT
FUNDING FOR THE LOW INCOME HOME
ENERGY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
DEPARTMENT WORKS WITH A NETWORK
OF AGENCIES TO PROVIDE PAYMENTS
FOR UTILITY BILLS EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE TO PREVENT. HOME
ENERGY SHUT OFF EMERGENCY
HEATING AND COOLING REPAIR AND
WEATHER STATION SERVICES.
THESE CRITICAL SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED TO PROBABLY TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS
EVERY YEAR. MANY OF THESE
HOUSEHOLDS INCLUDE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS SUCH AS THE ELDERLY
DISABLED AND.
CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF FIVE.
THE LIE YOU GRANT FOR FEDERAL
FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN WAS A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY POINT EIGHT MILLION.
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
FUNDING IS USED FOR WEATHER IS A
XIN SERVICES.
THE DEPARTMENT ALSO RECEIVED A
RELATIVELY SMALL GRANT OF SIX
POINT TWO MILLION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY FOR THE
WEATHER STATION ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM.
AND IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET THE
DEPARTMENT RECEIVED EIGHTEEN
MILLION OF GREENHOUSE GAS
PRODUCTION FUNDING. FOR THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
WHICH PROVIDES SOLAR PEAVEY.
SOLAR WATER HEATERS AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MEASURES AND LOW
INCOME SINGLE FAMILY AND MULTI
FAMILY DWELLINGS TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
SAVE ENERGY.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THE
DEPARTMENT PROPOSES A TOTAL
SPENDING OF TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
NINE MILLION ALL OF WHICH IS
FEDERAL FUNDING.
OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS
FUNDING FOR THE DEPARTMENTS
FEDERAL PROGRAMS HAS REMAINED
RELATIVELY CONSISTENT AND WE
ANTICIPATE LEVEL FUNDING FOR THE
COMMUNITY SERVICES BLOCK GRANT.
FUNDING FOR THE LOW INCOME HOME
ENERGY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WAS
INCREASED BY CONGRESS THIS YEAR.
WITH CALIFORNIA ESTIMATED TO
RECEIVE OF TO AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
WHILE WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED THE
FINAL WORD IF THESE ESTIMATES
ARE CORRECT CALIFORNIA WILL
RECEIVE AROUND A HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION FOR TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN.
AND ALTHOUGH THE PRESIDENT'S
PROPOSED BUDGET FOR TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN AGAIN RECOMMENDS
ELIMINATING ARE FEDERAL
PROGRAMS.
THERE CONTINUES TO BE SUPPORT
FOR THESE PROGRAMS AND CONGRESS
AS DEMONSTRATED THIS YEAR AND
WILL WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR STATE
AND FEDERAL PARTNERS TO MONITOR
THE STATUS OF THESE PROGRAMS AS
THE FEDERAL BUDGET. BLOCK
CONTINUES TO PROGRESS.
ON THE RELATIVELY POSITIVE NOTE
CALIFORNIA WILL ALSO RECEIVE
APPROXIMATELY NINE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS AS A RESULT OF
THE LEGAL SETTLEMENT. BETWEEN
THE FEDERAL ENERGY REGULATORY
COMMISSION AND BARCLAYS BANK TO
RESOLVE ALLEGATIONS OF ENERGY
MARKET MANIPULATION.
THIS ONE TIME PAYMENT IS TO BE
USED IN ACCORDANCE WITH OUR LIVE
HEAP GUIDELINES OUR LOW INCOME
HOME ENERGY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
GUIDELINES.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE NETWORK
OF LOW INCOME HOME ENERGY
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS.
THE DEPARTMENT IS PROPOSING TO
USE THESE FUNDS FOR
WEATHERIZATION SERVICES THAT
WILL HAVE A LONG TERM IMPACT ON
REDUCING UTILITY COSTS FOR LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
I WHAT I WANT TO CLOSE BY JUST
STATING THAT CSTO OF COMMITTED
COORDINATING STATE EFFORTS TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO CLAIM THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT ONE OF
THE MOST EFFECTIVE TOOLS FOR
REDUCING POVERTY.
FOR A SECOND YEAR THE DEPARTMENT
HAS PARTNERED WITH THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD TO ADMINISTER TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN STATE GENERAL
FUND. FOR GRANTS TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH TO
PROMOTE THE CAL EITC THE
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT. IN ADDITION THE
DEPARTMENT LEAVES A REDUCING
POVERTY WORKERS MADE UP OF
PUBLIC AGENCIES NONPROFITS AND
ASSOCIATIONS.
TO PROMOTE AWARENESS OF E. I. T.
SEE AN INCREASE IN CLAIMS AND
DIE THANK YOU AND I'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. A GOOD DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE EARLIER.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE ONE.
SEEING NONE ALL BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS FRONT QUESTIONS THAT
WE MAY HAVE.
I WANTED TO GET A LEVEL OF
DETAIL MORE IF I COULD ABOUT THE
DISGORGEMENT FUNDS WHICH YOU
JUST REFERENCE REGARDING THE BY
PLAY SETTLEMENT CAN YOU
ELABORATE. ON SPECIFICALLY SAID
IT WAS UNDER THE LIGHT HEAP
GUIDELINES BUT CAN YOU GO INTO A
LEVEL OF DETAIL ABOUT HOW THOSE
FUNDS WILL BE SPENT.
SO THAT THE DOLLARS ON THAT ARE
BEING PROVIDED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
A PROVISIONS ARE THAT IT IS
USED TO LOW INCOME HOME ENERGY
ASSISTANCE GUIDELINES SO THE.
IT'S VERY LOOSELY ARM.
CONTROLLED I GUESS FOR LACK OF A
BETTER WORD SO I AND ALL THAT
WERE REQUIRED TO DO IS TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE FOLLOWING THE LIE
HEAPED GUIDELINES SO THAT COULD
BE USED FOR UTILITY ASSISTANCE.
EMERGENCY HEATING AND COOLING
AND OR WHETHER IS ASIAN
SERVICES.
ATTA AND THE TIME LIMIT FOR YOU
AND IT'S BEEN IN THE DOLLARS
WERE HOPING TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH OUR LOCAL NETWORK OF
AGENCIES TO DISCUSS THE BEST WAY
OF ALLOCATING THE FUNDS TO OUR
NETWORK OF LOCAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
AND FOR THE USE OF WEATHER IS
ASIANS WE HAVE NOT YET. ARE COME
UP WITH THE EXACT MODEL OF WHAT
WE WOULD USE THE DOLLARS
SPECIFICALLY FOR IT MEANING WHAT
TYPE OF MEASURES IS THERE ABOUT
A DIFFERENT USE OF THE DOLLARS
THAT COULD BE USED TO AFFORD THE
MOST BENEFIT FOR THE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY.
HOW DO WE?
?
SOME OF THEM DIG A LITTLE BIT
SURE FURTHER INTO THIS IT IS
THERE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO.
HELPED TO INFLUENCE SOME OF
THAT DECISION MAKING A RULE
MAKING PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISADVANTAGED STRUGGLING WITH
HIGH ENERGY ARE. ABLE TO BE THE
FRONT OF THESE DISGORGEMENT
FUNDS OR. IS THERE A PROCESS
THAT IS CURRENTLY BEING
ESTABLISHED.
WELL TYPICALLY HOW THE
DEPARTMENT LOOKS AT ALLOCATING
FUNDS IS BASED ON THE POVERTY
POPULATION AS WELL AS THE COST
OF ENERGY THE FUEL COSTS
AS WELL AS CLIMATE FACTORS TO
DETERMINE YOU KNOW HOW THOSE
DOLLARS SHOULD BE ALLOCATED.
AND WE WILL BE WORKING WITH US
LIKE I SAID OUR LOW INCOME
PROVIDERS AS. WELL AS OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO DETERMINE THE
BEST USE OF THE FUNDS.
CAN YOU TELL ME A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THIS FEDERAL FUNDS
AND. A MAYBE BEFORE I GET INTO
THAT QUESTION I'LL JUST QUICKLY
ESTABLISHED QUORUM BECAUSE.
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS ARE GOING
MULTIPLE PLACE. SCIENCE. TO
OTHER MEMBERS.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA HERE. HARPER.
MATHIS HERE RUBIO.
WOULD
QUORUM.
LET ME FINISH WITH THE
DISGORGEMENT FUNDS IF I IF I CAN
CAN YOU UPDATE US ONCE YOU'VE.
HAD A DECISION OR DECIDED ON HOW
TO SO THAT WORK KEPT IN THE LOOP
THAT NOW I'D LIKE TO MOVE ON TO
FEDERAL FUNDING IF I COULDN'T
HAVE YOU ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT
MORE.
HE SAID THERE'S THE POTENTIAL
FOR A HUNDRED AND NINETY MILLION
HERE AND THEY HERE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUT TWENTY NINETEEN IS
STILL. UP IN THE AIR.
.
A CAN CAN YOU GO TO A LEVEL OF
DETAIL ABOUT WHEN WE WILL START
TO RECEIVE THOSE FUNDS AND SO WE
CURRENTLY FOR OUR FEDERAL FISCAL
YEAR TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
WE RECEIVED NINETY PERCENT OF
OUR LOW INCOME HOME ENERGY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FUNDING ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION.
DOLLARS SO WERE AWAITING THE
FINAL AWARD.
AND THEN WILL HAVE THOSE
DOLLARS TO DISTRIBUTE OUT TO OUR
AGENCIES
THIS UP THE COMMUNITY SERVICES
BLOCK GRANT SECTION THAT YOU
HAVE NOT RECEIVED THAT'S THE LOW
INCOME HOME ENERGY ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. OUR OUR COMMUNITY
SERVICES BLOCK GRANT WE RECEIVED
ABOUT HALF OF THE SIXTY TWO AND
A HALF MILLION AND THOSE DOLLARS
WE RECEIVE ON A QUARTERLY BASIS
WHERE OUR LOW INCOME HOME ENERGY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WE RECEIVE
NINETY PERCENT OF THOSE DOLLARS
INITIALLY. AND THEN THE
REMAINING TEN PERCENT AT A LATER
DATE SO WHAT ABOUT THOSE OF THE
DOLLARS THAT WERE STILL
AWAITING.
FOR OUR LOW INCOME HOME ENERGY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AND WE DID
HEAR THAT CONGRESS DID APPROVE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND BASED ON
THE ESTIMATES IT SHOULD BE ABOUT
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS MORE
WHICH IS THE HUNDRED NINETY IN
TOTAL FUNDING. SO.
COMPARING THIS YEAR TO LAST YEAR
WE WILL HAVE INCREASED FUND
HARASSED WEB TWENTY MILLION YES
THAT'S CORRECT.
.
LOOKING TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE DYESS
IF NOT THIS WAS AN INFORMATIONAL
ITEM WE WILL HOLD ISSUE ONE OPEN
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE TO.
ALRIGHT. I AM I.
WANT TO START BY THANKING YOU DR
ARAMBULA FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
IN OUR COMMUNITY SOLAR VENT AND
FOR ALSO MEETING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO DISCUSS THE. LIE
WITH THE EXPENDITURE PLAN AND
ALSO FOR THE STAFFS ASSISTANCE
IN OUR DEPARTMENT BRIEFING ON
OUR SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN CST HAS RECEIVED A TOTAL
OF A HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO
MILLION FOR THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM.
OF THESE FUNDS A HUNDRED TWENTY
ONE MILLION HAS BEEN ALLOCATED
FOR THE SINGLE FAMILY ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND SOLAR PEAVEY
PROJECTS.
AS DETAILED IN THE SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORT A TOTAL OF EIGHT HUNDRED
AND EIGHT THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY ONE SINGLE FAMILY
HOUSEHOLDS HAVE RECEIVED ENERGY
EFFICIENCY UPGRADES. AND. TWENTY
NINE HUNDRED HOUSEHOLDS HAVE
RECEIVE SOLAR PEAVEY SYSTEMS.
ABOUT FIFTY MILLION HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED FOR THE MULTI FAMILY
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND RENEWABLE
ENERGY PROJECTS.
FORTY NINE MULTI FAMILY PROJECTS
CONSISTING OF FOUR THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE
HOUSEHOLDS HAVE BEEN SERVED
UNDER THE PROGRAM.
FOR THE EIGHTEEN MILLION THAT
WAS APPROPRIATED AND THE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN FISCAL YEAR.
OF THE LOW INCOME FOR LOWER
INCOME MULTI FAMILY SOLAR AND
FARM WORKER WEATHER'S ASIAN
PROGRAMS THE DEPARTMENT INTENDS
ON ALLOCATING FIVE MILLION FOR
OUR COMMUNITY SOLAR PROJECT.
AND WE ALSO HAVE ANOTHER SEVEN
MILLION WILL BE ALLOCATED TO THE
MULTI FAMILY AND OF THE SEVEN
MILLION FIVE MILLION IS SET
ASIDE FOR THE MULTI FAMILY FARM
WORKER HOUSING.
COMPONENT AND THEN FINALLY FIVE
MILLION WILL BE ALLOCATED FOR
THE SINGLE FAMILY FARM WORKER
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND RENEWABLES
PROGRAM THE DEPARTMENT IS
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
HOLDING STAKEHOLDER.
OUR ENGAGEMENT OPPORTUNITIES
AND.
INFORMATIONAL FORUMS.
FOR THE POPE DESIGN OF THE
PROGRAM FOR BOTH THE COMMUNITY
SOLAR AND SINGLE FAMILY FARM
WORKER. WE HOPE TO MAKE AWARDS
IN THE FALL.
I'M AND I JUST LIKE TO NOTE THAT
ONLY TEN MILLION OF THE HUNDRED
NINETY TWO HAS YET TO BE AWARDED
SO ALL THE DOLLARS WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE TEN MILLION AND
THAT'S THE FIVE MILLION EACH FOR
THE COMMUNITY SOLAR AND THE FARM
WORKER HOUSING SINGLE FAMILY
FARM WORKER. HOUSING.
I'M REGARDING UNSPENT
APPROPRIATIONS
OF ARE FISCAL YEAR FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN IS CLOSE TO BEING FULLY
EXPANDED. AS WELL AS THE FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN STATE FISCAL YEAR
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN FUNDING FOR THE
MULTI FAMILY AND A SINGLE FAMILY
SOLAR. HOWEVER THE REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATOR THE LIE WITH TWO
POINT OH WHICH WAS A SINGLE
FAMILY COMPONENT.
WAS IMPLEMENTED LATE DUE TO
ISSUES THAT WERE NOT WITHIN THE
CONTROL OF THE REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATORS.
SINCE ANY FUNDS REMAINING WILL
RIVER THE DEPARTMENT SUBMITTED A
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL TO ENSURE
THAT THE FUNDING IS AVAILABLE.
FOR SERVICES TO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS AS INTENDED. IF THE
BCP IS APPROVED CST WILL PROVIDE
THE REGIONAL ADMINISTRATORS WHAT
THE CONTRACT EXTENSION FOR TIME.
AND THIS BCP IS SIMILAR TO THE
ONE THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAD LAST
YEAR AND WAS APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE FOR OUR FIFTEEN
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN.
FUNDING.
AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT WITH THE
EXTENSION THE FUNDS WILL BE
FULLY EXPENDED.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OLEO.
JENNY FELLOW AT THE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE HAVE REVIEWED THAT
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL FOR THE
REAPPROPRIATION AND WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS OF THAT.
WE WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE TO.
NO SORRY AND MAY HAVE ONE OTHER.
FEW PANELISTS HERE THROUGH
SECOND.
WE'VE DONE THIS ALL SUMMER FROM
CENTRAL COAST ENERGY SERVICES
FOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CENTRAL
COAST ENERGY SERVICES WE PROVIDE
LIKE HEAT FUNDED SERVICES TO
COMMUNITIES IN MONTEREY. SALMON
TALE SANTA CRUZ AND SAN BENITO
COUNTIES.
WE RECENTLY COMBINED WITH LOCAL
STAFF TO SERVE THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AS SAN
FRANCISCO PENINSULA ENERGY
SERVICES.
WHERE ONE OF FORTY TWO LOCAL
ENERGY SERVICE PROVIDERS UNDER
CONTRACT TO CSD?
UTILITY PAYMENT ASSISTANCE AND
HELP WITH SHUT OFFS ARE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES THIS NETWORKS
PROVIDES IN EVERY COUNTY.
WE ALSO VISIT THE HOMES OF THE
LOW INCOME AND NEEDY TO INSTALL
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY.
MEASURES.
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE PART OF THE
FABRIC OF EACH OF THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE.
WE PROVIDE QUALITY SERVICE LOCAL
JOBS AND TRAINING AND ECONOMIC
CONTRIBUTION AT THE NEIGHBORHOOD
LEVEL.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF LIGHT
WITH.
AND CONTINUED FUNDING FOR THE
CRITICAL PROGRAM THAT IT IS.
ACCORDING TO SEE STDS
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN SERVED. THROUGH LIFE HE BY
WITH.
WHILE THERE ARE NUMBER OF
VALUABLE COMPONENT SUPPLY WITH
IN THE SINGLE FAMILY WHETHER AID
STATION PROGRAM ALONE. NINE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
ONE DWELLINGS HAVE BEEN SERVED.
BY BE LIKE HE PROVIDERS.
THIS ADDED THE VALUE OF TWENTY
THREE POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
TO THE PROGRAM.
I'M MORE IMPORTANTLY WE ADDED
HEALTH AND SAFETY MEASURES IN
EACH OF THESE HOMES.
THAT CAN'T BE FUNDED WITH GIGI
R. F. MONIES.
I WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN THE CREATION AND PASSAGE OF
LIE WITH LANGUAGE IN SB EIGHTY
NINE LAST YEAR. WHICH WOULD
BELIEVE ME SPARK IMPROVEMENTS
IN BOTH SERVICE DELIVERY TO LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND COST
EFFECTIVE USE.
OF G. G. R. F. MONEY.
YOU MAY REMEMBER THAT WE VOICE
MANY CONCERNS LAST YEAR.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THESE
CONCERNS WERE NOT MEANT TO
QUESTION THE STATE'S NEED FOR
LIGHT WHAT SERVICES.
BUT RATHER THE AGENCIES
ADMINISTRATION AND DECISION
MAKING PROCESS
FOR THE PROGRAM.
WE'RE COMMITTED WERE INVESTED IN
IMPROVING EXPANDING AND
CONTINUING SERVICES THAT ADDRESS
THE ENERGY NEEDS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND THANKS IN PART TO THE
PASSAGE OF SB EIGHTY NINE AND
IT'S ANTICIPATED. IMPLEMENTATION
WE ARE HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF NEW LIVE WITH
FUNDING.
IN ADDITION TO THE HOME HEALTH
AND SAFETY NEEDS OF LOW INCOME
HOMES
THAT ARE THE PRIMARY FOCUS OF
THE LIFE HE PROGRAM.
WE RECOGNIZE THE TREMENDOUS NEED
TO PROVIDE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
MEASURES TO HOUSEHOLDS THAT
WOULD NOT OTHERWISE BE ABLE TO
AFFORD THEM.
WE HOPE WHY WHAT FUNDING WILL
CONTINUE TO BRETT PREVENT ANY
GAP IN DELIVERY OF THESE
CRITICAL SERVICES. AND REQUEST A
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION THIS BIT SCHOOL YEAR.
IF THE LEGISLATURE DETERMINES
THAT CST IS THE APPROPRIATE
AGENCY TO CONTINUE TO ADMINISTER
LIGHT WEB.
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
FOLLOWING IN IMPLEMENTING S. B.
EIGHTY NINE TO BEST ENSURE
SUCCESS.
NEW FUNDING FOR LIVE WHERE MUST
INCLUDE NEW PROGRAM
SOLICITATIONS AND GUIDELINES
THE OUR PRODUCTS OF CAREFUL
ANALYSIS IN COLLABORATION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND IMPLEMENTERS
FROM BOTH PHASES OF BY WAY.
IN SOLICITATIONS WEIGHT SHOULD
BE GIVEN TO POTENTIAL PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTERS APPLICANTS.
THAT HAVE EXISTING TIES TO THE
COMMUNITY THEY WOULD SERVE.
PROPOSAL SCORES SHOULD BE
EQUIVALENT TO THE LONGEVITY OF
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AND THE
STRENGTH OF LOCAL TIES
DEMONSTRATED BY APPLICANTS.
APPLICANTS WHO HAVE DEMONSTRATED
SUCCESS IN DELIVERING THE
SPECIFIC SERVICES SHOULD HAVE
PRIORITY STATUS.
TRANSPARENCY
GENUINE PUBLIC PROCESSES AND
MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT OF
POTENTIAL APPLICANTS SHOULD BE
INSURED.
WE ALSO URGE THE DEPARTMENT TO
BEGIN DISCUSSIONS REGARDING
PROGRAM ANALYSIS IMPROVEMENT AND
S. B. EIGHTY NINE INCORPORATION
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. TO ENSURE
THAT THERE ARE NO FURTHER DATE
DELAYS IN PROGRAM DELIVERY.
THANK YOU MISTER OSCAR.
NEXT WE HAVE LUIS SANCHEZ FROM
THE. COMMUNITY RESOURCE PROJECT.
HELLO YES MY UP THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE
LIGHT WENT.
I AGREE WITH MANY OF THE THINGS
THAT ARE SAID I TAKE ISSUE WITH
SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT
WERE SAID SO. LET ME BE PLAIN I
AM THE CHAIRMAN OF THE LOW
INCOME OVERSIGHT BOARD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S KIND OF
INTERESTING.
HERE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN IS THE
CONVERGENCE OF LOW INCOME ENERGY
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE.
REPRESENTING DIFFERENT FUNDING
STREAM.
CLEARLY THE CHALLENGE IS GOING
TO BE WHAT CAN WE DO TO
LEVERAGE.
YOU NO SERVICES AND FUNDING THAT
WOULD COME FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT WOULD COME FROM
THE STATE GOVERNMENT THAT WOULD
COME FROM UTILITIES AND
RATEPAYERS.
AND WHAT WOULD COME FROM.
BASICALLY THE ACTIONS OF CS BG
HAD WE HAD WE BRING ALL THIS
TOGETHER TO HAVE MAXIMUM OF
FACT.
WITH COMMUNITIES
SO LET ME ADDRESS SOME
METHODOLOGY IN TERMS OF MOVING
FORWARD I THINK THAT THE OPEN
SOLICITATION PROCESS.
MAKES A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
SENSE
YOU KNOW FOR CST I THINK WAS A
BOLD MOVE ON THEIR PART TWO
YEARS AGO. I WAS.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT CST BACK IN
THE NINETIES
SO I AM FAMILIAR WITH THEIR A
SERVICE PROVIDER NETWORK.
I AM ALSO FAMILIAR WITH THE FACT
THAT THOSE PARTICULAR FUNDS ARE.
EARMARKED THEY AREN'T THEY'RE
NOT PUT OUT FOR COMPETITIVE
SOLICITATION.
BUT HAVING SAID THAT LIE WET
WENT DOWN A DIFFERENT TRACK IN
THE WHOLE IDEA OF BEING
PERFORMANCE IN PRODUCTION.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT INCREASE
PERFORMS WHO PRODUCTION WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT MORE SERVICES
GOING INTO THE COMMUNITIES.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE SEE AT
THE CPC. IS CLIMATE CHANGE
CLIMATE CHANGE NOT ONLY IN TERMS
OF IMPACT.
I ENVIRONMENTALLY BUT TAUGHT
CLIMATE CHANGE IN TERMS OF
FINANCIAL BURDEN TO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS.
ESPECIALLY WERE REGIONS ARE
GETTING HOTTER AND THEY'RE
GETTING COLDER.
THE COST OF UTILITIES AS A
FINANCIAL COMPONENT FOR MANY OF
THESE HOLES HOUSEHOLDS IS.
NUMBER TWO CONSIDERATION AFTER
HOUSING.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT Y. WHAT
BRINGS AS PART OF THIS
CONVERGENCE OF PROGRAMS.
A COUPLE OF THINGS.
IT INTRODUCES THE SOLAR
COMPONENT BECAUSE AGAIN IF YOU
LOOK AT THE ENERGY PROGRAMS THAT
ARE BEING ADMINISTERED BY THE
UTILITIES.
THIRTY THE ENERGY SAVINGS
ASSISTANCE ACCOUNT IT DOES NOT
CONTAIN A SOLAR COMPONENT SO
WHAT IS THAT ME.
MANY OF THE COOLING MEASURES
THAT WE COULD INSTALL IN HOMES
AND FRESNO KERN KINGS COUNTY.
AT SOME OF THE OTHER MORE ARID
REGIONS AT THE STATE SIMPLY ARE
NOT ELIGIBLE BECAUSE THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS.
YOU BRING IN SOLAR.
THE PROBLEM IS IS ALLEVIATED.
SO HAVING SAID THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT LIE WHIP IS DONE
WITH AN OPEN SOLICITATION IT'S
IT BROUGHT AND IT HAS.
BY IT BROUGHT IN BEST OF BREED
CONTRACTORS.
FROM AGAIN THE EAST OR THE
ENERGY SAVINGS ASSISTANCE
ACCOUNT.
WITH THE UTILITY PROGRAMS.
THE OTHER THING THAT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ME TO MENTION
I'M ALSO ON THE BORDER DIRECTORS
WOULD LIKE OPERATE THE OF A
COMPASS CENA.
WHERE STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION OF
FARMWORKERS SERVICE PROVIDERS WE
ARE A MAJOR ADMINISTRATOR? AND
WE WORKED WITH LOCAL COMPANIES
IN TERMS TO LIE WITH PROGRAM.
SO GAS YOU KNOW THE PROGRAM
COULD COULD COULD USE SOME
CHANGES A YES WE DO AGREE WITH
S. B. EIGHTY NINE IN TERMS OF
ITS INTENT.
ARE WE FRANKLY I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE.
NO SORT OF BINDING CONTRACTUAL
PRIORITY.
WE THINK THAT.
AGAIN AND OPEN SOLICITATION
SHOULD FOCUS ON.
NOT ONLY EXPERIENCE NOT ONLY
ABILITY TO DELIVER SERVICES IN
THE COMMUNITY NOT ONLY THE
ABILITY TO GENERATE. JOBS IN THE
COMMUNITY IT SERVES.
BUT ALSO PRODUCTION PERFORMANCE
I KNOW THAT'S BEEN A MAJOR
ISSUE.
AND CONNECTION WITH THESE
DOLLARS IS GETTING THE SPENT
GETTING THEM SPENT EFFICIENTLY.
SO WE FEEL THAT OPENING UP THE
SOLICITATION ARE BRINGING IT
FORWARD. TO SUCCESSFUL SORTS OF
CONTRACTORS SORT OF NONPROFIT
RELATIONSHIPS THAT LIE WEPT TO A
LARGE DEGREE REPRESENTS.
WHICH IS A VERY UNIQUE I'VE BEEN
IN GOVERNMENT FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND THE BEST PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP THAT I SEE
OUT THERE DELIVERING SERVICES.
THROUGH A PUBLIC PURPOSE PROGRAM
TARGETING LOW INCOME.
IT'S THE COMBINATION OF FOR
PROFIT AND NONPROFIT SERVICE
PROVIDERS ON ENERGY ASSISTANCE.
WHICH SHOULD NOT TRY TO HAMPER
THAT WE SHOULD TRY TO ENCOURAGE
IT WE SHOULD TRY TO BUILD ON.
AND WE THINK MOVING FORWARD. IF
THE BCP IS A GRANTED AND WE
THINK IF YOU KNOW AGAIN WE LOOK
AT ALSO. NATALIE UNMET NEED BUT
THE WAITING LIST.
AND MULTI FAMILY ALONE IT
EXCEEDS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN TERMS OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE VAST AND HAVE
NOT RECEIVED SERVICES. THROUGH
THE LIE WHAT PROGRAM.
SO WE KIND OF UNDERSTAND THAT
GIGI R. F. IS IT'S A SORT OF A A
SITUATION WHERE IT'S YEAR TO
YEAR WE GET THAT.
BUT WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THE NEED
TO CREATE STABILITY AND
SUSTAINABILITY WITHIN THE
PROGRAM BASED ON PEOPLE'S NEEDS.
SO AGAIN.
I'M.
READY ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS.
WE ALSO SUPPORT ARE THE
CONTINUATION IN THE REFUNDING OF
THE PROGRAM.
WE SUPPORT OPEN SOLICITATION WE
SUPPORT. NO SORT OF WAITED
PRIORITY IN CONNECTION WITH WITH
CONTRACTORS.
AND WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU
KNOW AGAIN. US CST THROUGH THE
SOLICITATION PROCESS TO CONTINUE
TO USE PASTOR BREAK CONTRACTORS.
THAT WORK WITH OESA PROGRAM
ADDED CPC THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER SANTOS.
NEXT I BELIEVE WE'RE BOB CUSTOM
MADE.
BUT LOUIS SERGEANTS.
NOT.
DO YOU MEAN MIXED UP.
I THINK WE GOT THOSE MIXED UP
SORRY ABOUT THAT MILITARY READY.
THE I I YIELDED TO PARK HERE
YEAH.
SURE BANQUET AYE BATES MENA
SUVARI.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M WE SPONSOR SOME THE C. E.
O. COMMUNITY RESOURCE PROJECT.
HERE AND NOT SACRAMENTO.
THE FORTY FIVE YEAR OLD
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
SERVING SEVEN COUNTIES IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE ALSO PART OF THE.
LYE HEAT NETWORK.
PROVIDING.
WEATHERIZATION. AND.
ENERGY ASSISTANCE SERVICES TO
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES WERE ALSO
RECIPIENT OF THE PHASE TO LIE
WITH FUNDING AS A REGIONAL
MINISTRY FOR REGION ONE HERE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THAT INCLUDES BUTTE SACRAMENTO
SOLANO TO HIM A YOLO AND YUBA
COUNTIES.
WE RECEIVED NEARLY FIVE POINT
TWO MILLION IN THE FACE TO.
AND.
SYRUPY PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED
POVERTY INTERVENTION SERVICES
LIKE ENERGY EFFICIENCY. MEASURES
H. BACK REPAIR REPLACEMENT.
TO LEAD PAINT ABATEMENT
PROGRAMS
AND TWO SOLAR PEAVEY
INSTALLATION IN THE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND OUR REGION.
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS WE'VE
ADMINISTERED OVER NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ENERGY RELATED
CONTRACTS WORKING ON OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND HOMES AND
SERVING OVER FOUR HUNDRED LOW
INCOME. RESIDENTS.
BECAUSE OF OUR CONTINUOUS AND
LONG TERM EFFORTS ESTABLISHED
RELATIONSHIPS.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
PHASE TWO SERVICES WITHOUT
DELAY.
AS A RESULT WE'RE ON TRACK TO
COMPLETE OUR FACE TO CONTRACT
THIS MAY.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
BY THE END OF THE CONTRACT WE
HAVE OUR WE WOULD HAVE THE
WEATHER RISE THREE HUNDRED HOMES
AND PROVIDED ROOFTOP SOLAR TWO
HUNDRED FORTY. ONE HOMES IN THE
REGION ARE WITHIN THE FORTY
EIGHT DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THAT RESIDE THERE.
OUR SUCCESS HAS BEEN BASED ON
THOSE ELEMENTS OF S. B. EIGHTY
NINE.
SYRUPY HAS DECADES OF
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH AN
UNDERSTANDING LOW IN COMMUNITIES
THAT WE SERVE.
WE HAVE AN INTIMATE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE NEEDS OF
THOSE COMMUNITIES AND THE
RESIDENTS AND OTHER PARTNERS IN
THE AREA.
SYRUPY HAS A PROVEN TRACK
RECORD OF PROVIDING HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
MEASURES AS WELL AS ENERGY
EFFICIENT PROGRAMS OVER THAT
PERIOD OF TIME.
THE SERVICES ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO OUR STATES LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS
AND THERE'S NO OTHER STATE
PROGRAM THAT OFFERS IS
OPPORTUNITY TO THEM.
SEE YOUR PMI LOCAL SERVICE
PROVIDER COLLEAGUES URGE THAT
LIE WHIPPED CONTINUE IN THE
AMOUNT OF SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND BE INCORPORATED IN ORDER TO
MAXIMIZE THE PROGRAM EFFICIENCY
AND SURE CONTINUED SUCCESS.
SO. I AM AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE HAVE AMY REVELL.
WE CAN CREATE ONCE FOR HER THAT
GREAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ARAMBULA
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
AMIE REVOLVE WITH ASIAN PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK OR A PEN.
A PENSACOLA IS ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE FOR.
ASIAN AMERICAN IMMIGRANT AND
REFUGEE COMMUNITIES LIVING ON
THE FRONT LINES OF POLLUTION.
A PAN IS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA BIBLE JUSTICE
ALLIANCE OR SAY HI. AS WELL AS A
WE ON THE STEERING COMMITTEE OF
THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE EQUITY
COALITION WHICH IS A NETWORK OF
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
AIMED AT ENSURING EQUITABLE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CLIMATE
INVESTMENTS AND SPECIFICALLY IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
A PAN ALONG WITH SAID HA AND CC
EASY.
SUPPORT THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
I STRONGLY URGE LEGISLATORS TO
REVISE THE BUDGET.
TO INCLUDE FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM AT A LEVEL AS OUR
DIMENSION OF SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
PROGRAM FOR THE FOLLOWING
REASONS WHICH ARE OUTLINED IN
THE LETTER THAT WE SIGNED ON TO
FROM BY THE LOW INCOME OVERSIGHT
BOARD.
FIRST LIE WITH IS A UNIQUE AND
INNOVATIVE PROGRAM FUNDED BY THE
KIND INVESTMENTS PROGRAM.
LILA IS A MODEL PROGRAM IN THE
STATE FOR PROVIDING
COMPREHENSIVE CLEAN ENERGY
SERVICES INCLUDING ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND SOLAR. TO UNDER
HOW UNDERSERVED HOUSEHOLDS
LIVING IN BOTH SINGLE FAMILY AND
MULTI FAMILY HOUSEHOLDS.
AS COMPARED TO OTHER PROGRAMS
LIE WITH IS THE ONLY PROGRAM IN
WHICH A HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE
FUNDING SERVES LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS LIVING IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
REFLECTING DIRECT INVESTMENT IN
THE MOST EARTH OVERBURDENED
AREAS IN OUR STATE.
MY LIP IS ALSO UNIQUE IN
DELIVERING A ONE STOP SHOP WHOLE
BUILDING APPROACH BY OFFERING
DEEPER ENERGY RETROFITS COUPLED
WHEN POSSIBLE TO SELECT.
LOOKING AHEAD LILAC IS PLANNING
ON PILOTING INNOVATIVE
APPROACHES LIKE COMMUNITY SOLAR
AS WELL AS A FARMER COULD
PROGRAM THAT WE SEE BEING ABLE
TO BE SCALED AT OTHER AYE.
ENERGY AGENCIES.
SECOND LILAC DELIVERS CRITICAL
BENEFITS TO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS.
THE PROGRAM DESIGNED TO OVERCOME
BARRIERS THAT LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS FACE IN ACCESSING
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY.
CURRENTLY LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
HAVE AN AVERAGE ENERGY BURDEN
THAT'S APPROXIMATELY THREE TIMES
HIGHER THAN HIGH INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS.
WE KNOW THAT ARE HIGH ENERGY
BURDEN IS ASSOCIATED WITH HIGH
LEVELS OF STRESS AND MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES ARISING FROM
HOUSING INSTABILITY. HIGH
UTILITY EXPENSES AND THE RISK OF
UTILITY SHUT OFFS.
SINCE ITS LAUNCH IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN LILAC HAS SUCCESSFULLY
LOWERED ENERGY BILLS FOR OVER
SIXTEEN THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS
ACROSS THE STATE.
LEAVING MORE DISPOSABLE INCOME
AVAILABLE FOR OTHER HOUSEHOLD
COSTS LIKE RENT FOOD AND HEALTH
CARE.
LILAC DELIVERS OTHER TARGETED
COMMUNITY BENEFITS LIKE
WORKFORCE TRAINING AND PLACEMENT
AS WELL AS HEALTH AND SAFETY
IMPROVEMENTS.
AND FINALLY.
LILA PROMOTES CLIMATE RESILIENT
HOMES WHICH HAS ALREADY BEEN
MENTIONED.
WE'VE SEEN HOW CALIFORNIA'S HAVE
SUFFERED A DEVASTATING YEAR OF
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS RANGING
FROM WILDFIRES TO DEADLY HEAT
WAVES.
IN COMMUNITIES WHERE EXTREME
HEAT IS BECOMING THE NORM RISING
ENERGY COSTS THREATEN THE HEALTH
OF CHILDREN AND SENIORS AS
FAMILY STRUGGLE TO PAY THEIR
UTILITY BILLS.
INVESTMENT IN CLIMATE RESILIENCE
AND ADAPTATION MUST PRIORITIZE
THE MOST IMPACTED HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES AND WE BELIEVE THAT
LIE WHAT DOES THAT.
LILAH BRINGS THE BENEFITS OF
CLEAN ENERGY TO NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT NEED IT THE MOST.
FOR THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
PROGRAM ON AND.
SEE FUNDING AT A LEVEL OF
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION.
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXT WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE TO.
MISTER CHAIRMAN IS JUST MULLIN
BEHALF OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL WE ALSO VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THIS PROGRAM
YOU BELIEVE IT'S BEEN HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL. IT HELPS.
PROVIDE THAT CLIMATE RESILIENCE
TO THOSE LOW INCOME AT FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES THAT OTHERWISE
WOULDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO FUNDS
FOR SAFER AND HEALTHIER HOME SO
WE URGE A FULL I ALLOCATION OF
THAT SEVENTY FIVE MILLION. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR.
I'M
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MY NAME IS
SIMEON GANT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BLACK HEALTH NETWORK AND THE
GREEN TECH EDUCATION PROGRAM IN
SUPPORT OF THE SEVENTY FIVE ME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME A CHANCE
TO TESTIFYING IN FAVOR OF THE
PROGRAM RIGHT WHERE. I AM.
MEDICAL ETCETERA THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR RECALL BUT IF YOU WERE
COMPETING NOW SERVING ABOUT
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND FARM WORKERS
A YEAR.
AB WE ARE ONE OF THE CONTRACTORS
AND THAT I WHIP REGION FIVE. AND
WE CERTAINLY WANT TO CONTINUE TO
ASSESS OF THOSE PEOPLE IN THOSE
AREAS I HAVE MADE THE ARGUMENT
FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS BEFORE
A LOT OF LIVES LEGISLATORS.
THESE PROGRAMS RAGE THAT
DISPOSABLE INCOME OF OUR
FARMWORKERS.
WHICH IS ANOTHER ATTACK ON THE
PROPERTY AT THE SAME TIME THAT
WE REDUCE THAT THEIR CARBON
FOOTPRINT SIGNED FULL SUPPORT OF
THE PHONE MILLION FOR MY WHIP
PICK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS FOR
ANY QUESTIONS THAT WE MAY HAVE.
I HAVE ONE.
AM I WAS HOPING DIRECTOR YOU CAN
EXPANDS THERE WAS A QUESTION
RAISED IN THE STAFF COMMENT
SECTION ON WHY THE YIELDS ON THE
CAN PLEADED PROJECTS NOW COMES.
HAS REDUCED AND COMPARED TO
FUNDING OVER.
TIME FOR SOME OF THE ALLOCATIONS
AND WAS HOPING YOU COULD
ELABORATE ON THAT.
YEAH YOUR SECOND US THAT CALM
JASON WHEN WE CHIEF DEPUTY WITH
CST. OF SO WHEN YOU'RE MAKING
THOSE COMPARISONS IN THE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT BETWEEN.
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN IS IMPORTANT THAT
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AS A POINT IN
TIME SO FOR EXAMPLE WE KNOW
THAT.
WITH MANY OF THE PROGRAMS ARE
STILL IN PLAY AND THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE ONGOING.
THIS CAN BE CONTINUING PROGRAM
OPERATIONS IN EXPENDITURES SO WE
WAS CONTINUE TO SEE ADDITIONAL
PROJECTS.
BE REPORTED.
OVER THE COURSE OF TIME WHERE
HAS AND FOURTEEN FIFTEEN IT
REFLECTS PRETTY MUCH THE END
RESULT WITHIN THE END RESULT OF
EXPENDITURE. AN EXAMPLE WOULD
BE.
FOOD THAT THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS ITEM THAT WAS
APPROPRIATED OUR ALLOCATED TO
SINGLE FAMILY SO THE PROGRAM.
WE WELL THERE WAS TEN POINT
NINE IN THAT WE HAD TEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF EXPENDITURES THAT
WERE REFLECTED IN THE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT.
THIS UP THAT TEN MILLION DOLLARS
INCLUDED PROJECT EXPENDITURES AS
WELL AS A WORKING CAPITAL
ADVANCES THAT WERE ISSUED TO THE
CONTRACTOR. AND WE ALSO
INDICATED THAT HIS I THINK THAT
REPORT REFLECT ITS TWO HUNDRED
FORTY SOME ODD PROJECTS. BUT
SINCE OVER THE SINCE THE
ISSUANCE OF THE REPORT WE HAVE.
THERE'S BEEN A HUNDRED EIGHTY
SIX ADDITIONAL PROJECTS THAT
HAVE BEEN REPORTED IN THE FIRST
QUARTER WITH ANOTHER HUNDRED
SIX.
IMPLANT FOR THE SECOND QUARTER
WHICH WOULD PRETTY MUCH BRING
THOSE HOLES IN WITHIN TARGET.
APPRECIATE THE ANSWER IT'S.
NICE TO GET THAT NEXT LEVEL OF
DETAIL AND SOME.
.
HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT THE FUNDS
THAT WE ARE EXPANDING OUR
IMPLEMENTED EXPEDITIOUSLY IS
THERE ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO ON
OUR SIDE?
TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE GETTING
SPENT AND I'M.
AS APPROPRIATE OF A TIME AS
POSSIBLE.
HOME.
WEEKEND ETHICS IMPORTANCE
UNDERSTAND THAT WITH THE LIE
WHIP. APPROPRIATION THAT WE
RECEIVED TO DATE A FUNDS FOUND
ITS FUNDS OF OUR THE DIFFERENCE
A PROGRAM SO IT AND. THEY TEND
TO BE A FOCUS ON ONE PARTICULAR
PROGRAM OVER ANOTHER.
AND TO OVER THE PAST
THREE OR FOUR YEARS THE
DEPARTMENT IS USE THOSE DOLLARS
TO INTO IMPLEMENT NEW PROGRAMS.
SEWING IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAMS IT
DOES REQUIRE A CERTAIN PROCESS
THAT WE FOLLOW THAT'S ALSO.
BEEN FURTHER EMPHASIZE IN S. B.
EIGHTY NINE PROVIDE I'M STATUTE
THAT'S.
THAT'S BEEN PASSED BUT NEW
PROGRAMS A CAR.
PROGRAM DESIGN STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT. AND MANY CASES CA
COMPARED THE PROCUREMENTS AND
WHAT NOT SO GOING FORWARD.
I THINK WHAT WE CAN DO IS TO
START TO CONVENE MEETINGS AS
EARLY AS POSSIBLE TO. MAKE A
VALUATIONS OF OF.
APPROACHES THAT WORK AND HOME
AND THAT THE THINGS THAT HAVEN'T
WORKED AS WELL AS I'M STUCK
HAVING.
CONVERSATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
TO GET THEIR INPUT AND TRY TO
ACCELERATE NAM.
THE THE PROGRAM DESIGN. ELEMENTS
OR ASPECTS OF ANY PROGRAMS THAT
WE WISH TO FIND GOING FORWARD.
AND I WANT TO ASK A QUESTION AND
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER BUT
WANTED TO UNDERSTAND IF THERE'S
A SATURATION DYNAMIC.
IS THERE A IS THERE A POINT
WHERE.
MANY OF OUR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ARE SATURATED OR. IS
THERE SUCH A.
STILL ONGOING.
NEED.
THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WELL I THINK I'M ONE
OF THE ASPECTS THAT DEFINITELY
THERE ISN'T. AN ISSUE A
SATURATION HOUSE TO DO WITH THE
MULTI FAMILY AS AND ME VERY IN A
LOT OF LOW INCOME.
INDIVIDUALS LIVING MULTI FAMILY
BUILDINGS AND WE HAVE NOT HAD A
A PROGRAM THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. SO THAT'S
DEFINITELY.
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND AND THERE'S
DEFINITELY A NEED THERE ARE THE
SAME WITH THE SOLAR PEAVEY.
AND THOSE ARE THE PROGRAMS THAT
NOW ARE DOING. REALLY WELL AND
THAT THAT CHALLENGE WITH THE
MULTI FAMILY IT LOOKS ON PAPER
THAT BECAUSE THE EXPENDITURES
ARE BEING REPORTED. THAT THERE
IT'S NOT HAPPENING FAST ENOUGH
BUT THE DOLLARS ARE COMMITTED
INTO PROJECTS BUT WE DON'T
REPORT THOSE UNTIL THE PROJECT
IS COMPLETED SO THOSE DOLLARS
ARE COMMITTED AND THEY'RE BEING
USED BUT WE DON'T WANT TO. HAVE
IT SHOWN AS AN EXPENDITURE AND
UNTIL THE PROJECT IS COMPLETE
AND THAT TAKES.
TIME TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
WITHOUT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE TO
OPEN BUT ONE OF THE THANK YOU'S
DIRECTOR ACCEPTED A DIRECTOR FOR
COMING DOWN TO FRESNO.
OFTENTIMES THAT WE FELT LIKE WE
GET OVERLOOKED IN IT WAS NICE TO
HAVE YOU COME TO MY BACKYARD SO
THANK. YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WHEN YOU'RE READY AYE GOOD
AFTERNOON. PARK BECKLEY CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES HERE WITH ME TODAY IS
IRENE BREAKS HIS OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR ADMINISTRATION.
THE DEPARTMENT CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES.
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ESTABLISHING
ENFORCING COLLECTING AND
DISTRIBUTING CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE CURRENTLY SERVE A CASELOAD
OF ONE POINT TWO MILLION
FAMILIES WHICH IS.
SERVING A THREE MILLION PARENTS
AND CHILDREN.
OVER THE LAST FEDERAL FISCAL
YEAR TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WHERE WE HAD TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ARE HAPPY TO
REPORT THAT WE COLLECTED TWO
POINT FOUR BILLION IN CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS.
TO BILLION OF WHICH WENT
DIRECTLY FAMILIES.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND CHILD
SUPPORT IS MEASURED BY FIVE
FEDERAL PERFORMANCE MEASURES.
AND THOSE MEASURES ARE PATERNITY
ESTABLISHMENT COLLECTIONS ON
CURRENT SUPPORT COLLECTIONS ON A
REYES A CHILD SUPPORT ORDER IS
ESTABLISHED AND ATTORNEYS
ESTABLISHED.
WHILE IN FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY SEVENTEEN OUR PERFORMANCE
IS RELATIVELY FLAT.
WE ARE HAPPY TO REPORT THAT WERE
SO WITH AND. OF THE TOP TWENTY.
STATES AND TERRITORIES I'M ON
THOSE FEDERAL FOR ITS MEASURES.
WE ALSO HAVE CERTAIN STATE
MEASURES THAT WE USE TO MEASURE
OUR PERFORMANCE THAT WE CALL
PRACTICE INDICATORS. ON BETWEEN
FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
THAT WE'RE ABLE TO INCREASE THE
PERCENTAGE OF.
FAMILIES THAT PAY NINETY
PERCENT OR MORE ON THEIR CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS AND BY
PERCENTAGE POINT AT TWO THIRTY
NINE POINT THREE PERCENT.
I'M ENTITLED ISSUE THE
COLLECTIONS BETWEEN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN. WE
INCREASE OUR COLLECTIONS BY
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION OR ONE
POINT TWO PERCENT.
AND.
IN TERMS HAVE.
JUST REALLY COLLECTIONS FOR
CASE SAID THE MONEY GOING
DIRECTLY TO FAMILIES. REBEL
INCREASED.
OUR COLLECTIONS FOR CASE BY
SEVENTY DOLLARS OR THREE POINT
FIVE PERCENT.
SO VERY MEANINGFUL TO OUR
FAMILIES.
I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT.
.
SOME PAYMENT INITIATIVES THAT WE
HAVE LAUNCHED.
AND TWENTY FIFTEEN WE DECIDED TO
EXPAND.
PAYMENT OPTIONS TO ALL OF OUR
FAMILIES.
ESPECIALLY CHILD SUPPORT
OBLIGOR IS TO ARE PART OF A CASH
BASED ECONOMY.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WE LAUNCHED
HUMAN A PAYMENT SERVICES
MONOGRAM AND.
PAINTER ME. THESE ARE PAYMENT
COUNTERS I CAN FIND IN A LOT OF
RETAIL LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. I'M THROUGH THOSE PAYMENT
METHODS AND FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY SEVENTEEN RAIL TO COLLECT
THIRTEEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
WE ALSO INSTALLED.
.
ED PAYMENT KIOSKS AND OUR CHILD
FOR AGENCIES. OF THOSE PAYMENT
COUNT SEVEN LAST YEAR HAD
COLLECTED FORTY ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS AND CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS. AND JUST
RECENTLY RELAUNCHED A MANY
PAYMENT SERVICE WHILE.
NEW TO US PAYPAL AND THAT WAS
ADDED TO OUR WEBSITE SO THAT OUR
PUBLIC AREAS COULD PAY FOR THAT
PAYMENT IS PAYMENT METHOD AS
WELL.
I'D NOW LIKE TO.
CHARTED EVERTS YOU MISS BREAKS
TO TALK ABOUT OUR ESTIMATE.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ESTIMATES.
DECSS ESTIMATES THAT IT WILL
COLLECT TWO POINT FOUR SIX FIVE
BILLION IN CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS. IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WHICH IS AN
INCREASE OF THIRTY FIVE MILLION
OR ONE POINT FOUR PERCENT OVER
THE PRIOR YEAR.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN DECSS ESTIMATES THAT WE
WILL COLLECT TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION. WHICH IS AN INCREASE OF
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION AND OR ONE
POINT FIVE PERCENT OVER THE
CURRENT YEAR.
DECSS INCLUDED IN ITS ESTIMATE
INCREASED OF A HUNDRED NINETEEN
THOUSAND OR FORTY ONE THOUSAND
AND GENERAL FUND. TO IMPLEMENT
THE NEW IRIS BACKGROUND CHECK
REQUIREMENT FOR.
SUPPORT STAFF THAT HAVE ACCESS
TO FEDERAL TAX INFORMATION. AND
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
FINALIZING THOSE POLICIES. WILL
BE IMPLEMENTING THAT BACKGROUND
CHECK PROCESS.
DURING THIS CALENDAR YEAR.
NOW ALSO IN OUR ESTIMATE IS THE
RECEIPT OF AN ADDITIONAL NINE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWOTHOUSAND.
AND FEDERAL INCENTIVES BASED ON
OUR PERFORMANCE ON THE FIVE
FEDERAL PERFORMANCE MEASURES.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ILIO.
INCOMES.
ONE NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
ISSUE ONE.
SEEN NONO BRING IT UP TO THE
DYESS. YOU'D MENTIONED THE
FEDERAL PERFORMANCE MEASURE HAS
ARE THERE ANY THAT YOU'RE
FOCUSING ON EXPLICITLY TO
IMPROVE MORE INTENSELY THAN
OTHERS.
WHAT WE?
ARE ATTEMPTING TO DO IS REALLY
FOCUS ON I'M DISPUTED
COLLECTIONS FOR OUR CUSTOMERS
AND WE BELIEVE THAT.
EACH ONE OF THOSE PERFORMANCE
MEASURES WILL BE AFFECTED IF WE
FOCUS ON YESTERDAY COLLECTIONS
ARE FAMILIES.
SO WHETHER IT'S COLLECTIONS ON
CURRENT SUPPORT COLLECTIONS ON A
REYES SADDAM ESTABLISHING OUR
CHILD SUPPORT ORDERS.
ALL OF THOSE COULD HAVE BE
POSITIVELY AFFECTED BY ISSUED
COLLECTIONS BUT NOT ANYONE
SPECIFICALLY ARE REALLY JUST
LOOK OUT WE YOU KNOW WE WE. YOU
KNOW IN THE COLLECTION MEASURES
WE TEND TO DO PRETTY WELL ON
PATERNITY ESTABLISHMENT SO WE
DON'T PUT AS MUCH FOCUS ON THAT.
BUT THE OTHER ONES ARE VERY
INSTRUMENTAL.
UNIT ALSO SAY THAT YOU KNOW WE
ARE FOCUS ON DIFFERENT PRACTICES
SUCH AS NEGOTIATED CHILD SUPPORT
ORDERS. I'M RATHER THAN JUST
HAVING WATERS GO BY DEFAULT
PRESUMING THAT SOMEBODY HAS A
MINIMUM WAGE JOB OR WORKS FORTY
HOURS A WEEK. REALLY TRYING TO
BRING BOTH PARENTS INTO THE
OFFICE TO NEGOTIATE THOSE ORDERS
WE FIND THAT THOSE ORDERS TEND
TO PAY BETTER THAN ORDERS
ESTABLISHED BY DEFAULT.
YEAH.
* WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
ISSUE ONE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE TO.
I THINK WE NEED ONE MORE SPOT IF
WE CAN.
WE'LL START WITH CARRIE GILBERT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ARAMBULA
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CARRIE GILBERT AND I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF FRESNO COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES.
WE CALIFORNIA FORM THE
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES AND PRODUCTS
CENTRALIZED IN MORE UNIFIED.
FOCUS TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY THE FUTURE FUNDING
METHODOLOGY AND STRUCTURE WAS
LACKING.
HERE WE ARE YEARS AFTER THE
FORMATION OF THE DEPARTMENT AND
WE REMAINED ESSENTIALLY FLAT
FUNDED.
OUR LOCAL COUNTY CHILD SUPPORT
AGENCIES ARE THE HEART OF THIS
PROGRAM THIS IS TRULY WHERE THE
DIRECT SERVICES ARE PROVIDED TO
THE FAMILIES.
CHILD SUPPORT FAMILY OUR CHILD'S
PER PROVIDES FAMILIES WITH MUCH
NEEDED INCOME HELPING WITH THE
BASIC LIFE NECESSITIES SUCH AS
FOOD. SHELTER AND CLOTHING.
OVER TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
FAMILIES OF FRESNO COUNTY FALL
BELOW POVERTY LEVEL. AND OVER
TWENTY NINE PERCENT OF THE
CHILDREN LIVE IN FOOD INSECURE
HOUSEHOLDS.
I AM HERE TODAY IS ONE OF THE
FOURTEEN COUNTIES SIGNIFICANTLY
UNDERFUNDED.
DUE TO RELATIVELY FLAT FUNDING
AND INCREASED OPERATING COSTS
OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS.
PRESIDENT COUNTY CHILD SUPPORT
HAS HAD SIGNIFICANT STAFFING
REDUCTIONS.
AND TWO THOUSAND SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE WE HAVE BEEN
FORCED TO REDUCE OUR STAFFING
ALLOCATIONS BY ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE POSITIONS.
BRING US DOWN TO TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR ALLOCATIONS FOR OVER
SIXTY THOUSAND CASES.
THOUGH WE STRIVE TO PROVIDE
EFFICIENT AND EXCELLENT CUSTOMER
SERVICE MORE THAN NOT DUE TO OUR
STAFFING LEVELS. WE'RE FORCED
INTO REACTIONARY CASE WORK.
ARE FRESNO COUNTY CHILD SUPPORT
HAS DEMONSTRATED YEAR OVER YEAR.
THAT IT IS A SOLID INVESTMENT
FOR THE STATE GENERAL FUND.
FOR EVERY DOLLAR INVESTED ON OUR
PROGRAM IT PRESIDENT COUNTY THE
TOTAL DISTRIBUTED COLLECTIONS IS
GREATER THAN FOUR DOLLARS.
THIS INCLUDES RECRUITMENT TO THE
STATE GENERAL FUND AND MONIES
DIRECTLY TO THE FAMILIES WHICH
HELPS WITH SELF SUFFICIENCY. AND
COST AVOIDANCE.
AND STATE FISCAL YEAR SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN FOR EVERY STATE
GENERAL FUND DOLLAR THAT WAS PUT
INTO FRESNO COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES.
WE RECOUPED A DOLLAR THIRTY
THREE FOR YOUR GENERAL FUND.
WE GIVE YOU A BETTER RETURN ON
YOUR MONEY THAN ANY SAVINGS
ACCOUNT.
I END WHERE I STARTED.
THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN FLAT FUNDED
FOR FAR TOO LONG.
I AM HERE IS ONE OF THE FOURTEEN
COUNTIES ASKING YOU TO INVEST IN
US.
FORTY TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS OF YOUR STATE GENERAL
FUND MONIES.
ANNUALLY.
WITH THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING WE
CAN PROVIDE BETTER CORE SERVICES
IN A MORE EFFICIENT AND
EXPEDIENT MANNER. WE CAN
INCREASE THE COLLECTIONS TO
FAMILIES AND WE CAN INCREASE THE
RECRUITMENT TO THE STATE GENERAL
FUND.
INVESTINGIN OUR FOURTEEN
COUNTIES NOW IS TOO FULL.
IT CREATES AN EVEN PLAYING FIELD
ALLOWING US TO PROVIDE THE SAME
GREAT SERVICE LEVEL. AS OTHER
COUNTY CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES.
AND IT ALSO SET A NEW BASELINE
TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THE
FUTURE FUNDING METHODOLOGY AND
STRUCTURE OF THIS PROGRAM.
INVESTING AND CALIFORNIA'S TILES
WERE PROGRAM IS A SOLID
INVESTMENT OF YOUR STATE GENERAL
FUNDS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU MISTER GILBERT NEXT WE HAVE
LAURIE.
ALSO GIVEN US THIS AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS LAURIE CREWS AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR THE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES. I LEAD ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE DEDICATED CHILD
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS
IN THE WORK OF DELIVERING
CRITICAL CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES
TO THE CHILDREN FAMILIES WHERE
PRIVILEGE SERVE.
IT IS FOR OUR STAFF AND
CUSTOMERS AT MY COLLEAGUES IN I
FOR REQUESTING. FORTY TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS FOR USE IN OUR FOURTEEN
COUNTIES.
WE BELIEVE THAT OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE COR SERVICES HAS BEEN
NEGATIVELY AFFECTED BY THE FLAT
FUNDING WE HAVE RECEIVED. FROM
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWO. ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
IT IS A SERIOUS OBSTACLE TO
SERVING THE FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
STILL IN NEED.
LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES
HAVE NOT RECEIVED AN INCREASE TO
THEIR BASE ALLOCATIONS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWO.
OUR COSTS HAVE RISEN HUNDRED
NINETEEN PERCENT.
STAFF SALARIES HAVE INCREASED AN
AVERAGE OF THIRTY SIX PERCENT.
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME OUR
ALLOCATION HAS RISEN ONLY ONE
PERCENT.
CAN YOU IMAGINE PAIN YOUR
HOUSEHOLD BILLS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN.
WITH THE SCENT SAME INCOME YOU
MADE IN TWO THOUSAND TWO.
DESPITE THESE CHALLENGES ARE
PROGRAM IS ONE OF THE BEST
INVALID VESTMENTS FOR STATE
FUNDING.
FOR EVERY ONE DOLLAR INVESTED
THE PROGRAM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MATCHES IT WITH TO.
IN FACT FOR THE FORTY TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS WE ARE
REQUESTING.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL
MATCH IT WITH EIGHTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A TOTAL OF
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY SIX MILLION.
THAT WILL BE ALLOCATED DIRECTLY
TO THE MOST UNDER FUNDED
TRANSFERRED AGENCIES.
JUST AS IMPORTANT IS THE FACT
THAT OUR PROGRAM. IS ONE OF THE
MOST EFFECTIVE IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST CHILDHOOD POVERTY.
RELIABLE AND CONSISTENT CHILD
SUPPORT HELPS FAMILIES IN NEED
TO REDUCE THEIR RELIANCE ON
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE.
AS MONTHLY CHILD SUPPORT
TYPICALLY ACCOUNTS
FOR FORTY PERCENT OF MONTHLY
INCOME FOR FRAGILE FAMILIES.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT WE CAN
COUNT ON ADDITIONAL COST
AVOIDANCE SAVINGS.
OF NEARLY FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT MAY BE USED FOR
OTHER STATE PROJECTS.
IN RETURN FOR THIS INVESTMENT.
WE COMMIT TO FOCUS WORK ON
REDUCING DELAYS THAT AFFECT THE
FAMILIES WE SERVE.
WE ALSO ANTICIPATE INCREASING
TOTAL COLLECTIONS.
FIVE PERCENT FOR EACH OF THE
FIRST TWO YEARS OF THE
INVESTMENT AND THEN TEN PERCENT
FOR YEARS THREE THROUGH FIVE.
THIS INCREASING COLLECTIONS
WILL BENEFIT FAMILIES AND
REIMBURSES STATES GENERAL FUND.
LAST WEEK WE HAD OUR HEARING IN
FRONT OF THE SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE.
SENATOR PAN ASKED US TO WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT. ON A WHOLE
LISTA CONSISTING OF A FUNDING
PLAN.
WITH OUR ASSOCIATION LEADING THE
EFFORT.
WE MET THIS PAST MONDAY WILL
MEET SEVERAL MORE TIMES OVER THE
NEXT WEEK AND HALF.
IF WE ARE VERY WILLING TO ENGAGE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND OUR
ASSOCIATION.
ON A LONG TERM FUNDING PLAN.
THAT WILL BENEFIT ALL
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES.
FIRST
WE NEED A PATCH FOR OUR FOURTEEN
COUNTIES.
THAT ONE ABLE US TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES OUR CUSTOMERS DESERVE.
AND WE FULLY UNDERSTAND THAT
YOUR COMMITTEE IS PRESENT WITH
MANY VALID AND NECESSARY
REQUEST.
FOR FUNDING. AND WE HOPE THAT
YOU WILL AGREE WITH US THAT
CHILD SUPPORT IS NOT ONLY A GOOD
INVESTMENT.
FOR THE STATE BUT THAT OUR
CUSTOMERS AND COMMUNITIES
BENEFITTED. FROM AN ACTIVE
ENGAGED LOCAL TRANSPORT OFFICE
FOR.
I ALSO WANTED THEM NOTE THAT
EACH OF YOU HAS. A BINDER THAT
WE HAVE PREPARED. THAT INDICATES
THE.
PROBLEM AND THE SOLUTION MORE
PERSPECTIVE. AS WELL AS
SUPPLEMENTARY MATERIALS THANK
YOU AGAIN THANK YOU MISS CRUZ
AND NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT AND.
IF I MAY I JUST WANTED TO START
BY ACTUALLY THANKING YOU FOR
MEETING WITH THE. ADVOCATES
DIRECTLY IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
BUT WAS WONDERING IF YOU COULD
TELL US A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
UPCOMING MEETINGS AND WHAT'S
PLANNED DURING THEM I THINK YOU
MADE ON APRIL NINETEENTH.
TWENTY FOURTH AND TWENTY SIXTH
AND I WANTED TO KNOW IF. THERE
WAS A PLAN OR ATTENDANCE FOR
THOSE CRACKED AS.
MISTER CHAIR.
THE I'M DEPARTMENT SELLS
SUPPORT SERVICES IS I'M WORKING
IN A COORDINATION WITH VLC
ESSAYS. ON THE STAKEHOLDER
QUEST.
I SHOULD STATE THAT THIS ISN'T
AND ADMINISTRATION SPONSORED.
PROPOSAL A WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THE PROPOSAL I'M AT
THIS MOMENT.
HOWEVER WE ARE.
MEETING PROVIDING I'M TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE WORKGROUP.
I THINK FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PERSPECTIVE IF
NEW MONEY IS TO BE ADDED IN FOR
THE CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM. UP WE
ARE LOOKING FOR MORE HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO.
THAT THE ISSUE.
IN TERMS OF HOW ANY NEW FUNDING
WOULD BE SPREAD ACROSS AN EFFECT
ALL TRANSPORT AGENCIES. I'M
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE FOCUS
RIGHT NOW IS ON THE FOURTEEN.
UNDERFUNDED COUNTIES.
BUT REALLY LOOKING FOR THAT
LONGER TERM PERSPECTIVE.
ALSO SOMETHING THAT'S
PERFORMANCE BASED IS IMPORTANT
SO WHAT OUTCOMES WOULD BE
ACHIEVED WITH THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. TOM I DO THINK THAT THE
WORK GROUP.
MEETING THAT WE HAD ON MONDAY
WAS VERY PRODUCTIVE I'M A LOT OF
GOOD IDEAS THAT WERE SHARED AND
EVERYONE'S KEEPING AN OPEN MIND
IN TERMS OF DIFFERENT
METHODOLOGIES AND MODELS.
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ONLY
OPENING COMMENTS ON THE SHE
TOOK.
I JACQUI AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AS WAS
MENTIONED WITH THE WORK GROUPS
WERE ALSO MAKING OUR BEST EFFORT
TO ATTEND THOSE WORK GROUPS I'M
PROVIDING THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT I MAY BE NEEDED
AND JUST OBSERVING. ANYTHING
THAT COMES UP IN THAT MIGHT BE
HELPFUL FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
PUBLISHED WAS WHAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE A WORLD'S PARTICIPATING
WHEN WE CAN IN THESE.
MEETINGS AND WE'RE ALSO HAPPY
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
WE WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE TO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
FIRST KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
FRESNO KERN.
SAN JOAQUIN MERCED AND
STANISLAUS FIVE OF THE UNDER
FUNDED COUNTIES THINK OVERLY TO
STRAIGHT DOWN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
OUT. TO A LOS ANGELES RIVERSIDE
SAN BERNARDINO THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING EXTENSIVELY A SINCE THE
FALL TO PUT TOGETHER A PROPOSAL
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER.
THEY'VE DEVOTED AN IMMENSE
AMOUNT OF TIME ESPECIALLY IN THE
LAST FEW WEEKS JUST AS THE.
SENATE AUTHENTIC WILL MEET WITH
THE DEPARTMENT ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS WE'VE HAD IS THE
CHICKEN AND THE EGG APPROACH
BECAUSE THERE ARE A COUNTIES
THAT ARE NOT UNDER FUNDED. AND
TO TALK ABOUT A REDISTRIBUTION
OF EXISTING RESOURCES MEANS THAT
WE'RE JUST MAKING THE WINNERS
AND LOSERS AND WE UNDERSTAND THE
LONG TERM GOAL IS TO HAVE A.
SENSIBLE RATIONAL DISTRIBUTION
OF THE DOLLARS
I THINK IN ORDER TO DO THAT. WE
NEED NEW ODD NEWS NEW RESOURCES
TO THE FOURTEEN IN ORDER TO HAVE
A A COLLABORATIVE APPROACH. THAT
EVERYBODY CAN LIVE WITH SO WE
ASK FOR ME RESOURCES FOR THEM
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE
COMMITMENT IS APPARENT TO
EVERYBODY THAT THEY WILL WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT ALEJO.
FINANCE TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING THAT WORKS FOR ALL
FIFTY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND YOUR STAFF TIME ON THIS
ISSUE. THANK HIM.
SEARCH OUR MEMBERS JOIN OF OR
SOME PATH URBAN CARRIES A
CALIFORNIA WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THIS ADDITIONAL FORTY
TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION FOR THE
UNDER FROM THE COUNTIES. SIX OF
WHICH URBAN COUNTIES A FRESNO
LOS ANGELES RIVERSIDE SACRAMENTO
STEINBERG DEAN ON SAN JOAQUIN.
THIS UP FUNDING PROVIDES AS YOU
FOR ESSENTIAL SERVICES TO LOW
INCOME FAMILIES CAN HELP REDUCE
POVERTY AND HELP SELF
SUFFICIENCY. NAM WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S ALSO A STRONG RETURN
INVESTMENT TO THE STATE. WE ALSO
ARE INVOLVED IN THE STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS AND PROCESS AND I THINK
THAT PAT DID MAKE GOOD PROGRESS
ON MONDAY.
HOWEVER I AGREE WITH THE SLANG
THAT AS LISTS STAY AT THE SENATE
HEARING WE NEED TO BRING OUT
ACCOUNT IS UP TO THE SAME OF YOU
EVEN LITTLE LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
BEFORE WE START TALKING ABOUT. A
FORMULA METHODOLOGIES BECAUSE
AND THIS IS GOING TO CREATE NEW
WHERE SOME LOSERS AND PROBABLY
MOST COUNTY WOULDN'T AGREE TO
THAT SO I THINK WE NEED TO.
CREATE A LEVEL PLAYING FROM
FIRST TO HAVE THAT COMMITMENT
AND THEN WE CAN HAVE A LONGER
FROM THE DISCUSSION OVER THE
SUMMER. COMMON THAT OUT BUT THAT
WERE IN SUPPORT AND APPRECIATE
YOUR AND INTEREST AND ATTENTION
THANK YOU THANK HIM.
JUSTIN GOT CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES THAT
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
FUNDING PROPOSAL AND WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE APPROACH OF PROVIDED
A NEW INVESTMENTS.
I'M AND THEN THAT LEADING TO THE
LARGER CONVERSATION ON THE
ALLOCATION ISSUES I'M SEE SAKAS
ALSO BEEN PARTICIPATED IN THOSE
ALLOCATION MEETINGS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO SOME FOREIGN. THANKS
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M VERONICA
RILEY THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
ONE OF THE FOURTEEN.
ADD JUST LAST WEEK A NEW STUDY
WAS RELEASED ON CHILD POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE MAY HAVE SEEN
IT.
DATA FROM THE CENSUS BUREAU AND
THE SUPPLEMENTAL POVERTY MEASURE
BOTH REVEALED THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS THE HIGHEST RATE OF BOTH
CHILDHOOD. AND ADULT POVERTY IN
THE ENTIRE NATION.
THE JUSTICE POVERTY RATE IS
TWENTY TWO POINT EIGHT PERCENT
FOR CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN WHICH
EQUATES TO OVER TWO MILLION
KIDS.
AMONG THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THIS REPORT FOR ADDRESSING THE
POVERTY ISSUE IS AND I QUOTE
CONTINUING TO STRENGTHEN CHILD
SUPPORT ENFORCEMENT PROGRAMS.
THAT WORK EFFECTIVELY WITH NON
CUSTODIAL PARENTS AND ENSURE
THAT SUPPORT REACHES THE
FAMILIES THAT NEED IT.
SINCE THE FOURTEEN UNDERFUNDED
COUNTIES MAKE UP ALMOST SEVENTY
PERCENT SEVENTY PERCENT OF THE.
ENTIRE CHILD SUPPORT CASELOAD IN
CALIFORNIA. AND INVESTMENT IN
THESE COUNTIES WOULD STRENGTHEN
OUR PROGRAMS AND WILL MOST
CERTAINLY GO A LONG WAY TO
ENSURING THAT THE FAMILIES WHO
NEED THE SUPPORT RECEIVER
SERVICES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI AM TIME YOU MORE ON THE
DIRECTOR OF TAME A COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES.
MY STAFF AND I ARE PASSIONATELY
ENGAGED IN THE WORK THAT WE DO
IN WORKING WITH PARENTS FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THEIR CHILDREN.
WE CONSTANTLY EVALUATE HOW WE
CAN HELP MAKE CHILD SUPPORT A
MORE RELIABLE SOURCE OF INCOME.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET THIS RIGHT
BECAUSE FOR SINGLE LOW INCOME
FAMILIES CHILD SUPPORT IS FORTY
PERCENT OF THEIR TOTAL INCOME.
FOR THE SEVERELY IMPOVERISHED IT
MAKES UP APPROXIMATELY SIXTY
PERCENT.
TO GIVE FAMILIES THE SERVICE
LAKE LEVEL THEY DESERVE ALL
COUNTIES
MUST BE APPROPRIATELY FUNDED TO
HAVE SUFFICIENT STAFFING LEVELS
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
ATTY GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY
I'M DIDN'T AGREE SHELVE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES.
IN LOS ANGELES WE HAVE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
CASES THAT'S TO UNDER FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND FAMILIES WE SERVE.
IT'S ABOUT ONE FIFTH OF THE
ENTIRE STATE LOAD CASELOAD.
WE PROJECT THIS YEAR THAT WE'RE
GONNA COLLECT OVER ONE HALF
BILLION DOLLARS ON BEHALF OF
THOSE FAMILIES.
I AM A BUDGET OF A HUNDRED EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS.
WE GET FROM STATE OF FEDERAL OF
SOURCES ONLY A HUNDRED AND FORTY
TWO MILLION.
THAT A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT GAP IS
MOSTLY BRIDGED BY THE RATHER
UNIQUE.
AND GENEROUS CONTRIBUTIONS FROM
THE LA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
THAT SAID THERE ARE TWO YEARS
AGO I UNFUNDED EIGHTY POSITIONS
THIS YEAR I'M IN FUNDING AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE
POSITIONS.
WITH FLAT FUNDING I PROJECT TO
ON FUND DOZENS OF POSITIONS IN
THE COMING YEAR.
A FIRST TO BE A ANTI POVERTY FOR
SOME BEHALF OF CHILDREN AND
BEHALF OF FAMILIES OF THAT CAN
SUSTAIN ITSELF THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SARAH HONEY CAT NAM THE DIRECTOR
OF TO. AMADOR COUNTY CHILD
SUPPORT AND I HAVE TO ADMIT
PUBLIC SPEAKING IS ONE OF MY
GREATEST FEARS AND I'M STANDING
HERE.
I'M STANDING HERE BECAUSE I NEED
TO KNOW LET YOU KNOW THAT I AM
ONE OF THOSE FOURTEEN. I HAVE A
CASE LOAD OF SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
CASES AND A THIRD OF THOSE ARE
RECEIVING PUBLIC ASSISTANCE.
AB TWENTY NINE STAFF AT THIS
TIME THIRTY INCLUDING MYSELF.
WE WANT. WHO WE KNOW THAT IF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING?
WE WOULD IT BE BETTER ABLE TO
SERVE OUR COMMUNITY BY WORKING
THOSE CASES WITH MORE HUMAN
INTERVENTION STAFFING WILL ALLOW
US TO WORK WITH PARENTS TO GET
RIGHT SIZE ORDERS. DO MORE EARLY
INTERVENTION AND WORK ON CASES
AND PARENTS IN HELPING THEM TO
FIND RESOURCES FOR THEM TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
I BELIEVE. WITH ADDITIONAL
STAFFING WE MAY BE ABLE TO MOVE
SOME OF THE CURRENTLY EIGHTY
CASES TO THE FORMALLY AIDED. AND
THEN CHILD SUPPORT THEN BECOMES
COST AVOIDANCE PROGRAM.
WHICH ISN'T IMPORTANT TO.
THE ENTIRE BUDGET.
ALL CHILDREN REGARDLESS OF THEIR
LOCATION SHOULD RECEIVE THE SAME
CARE ACROSS THE STATE THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WILL PROVIDE
THE SERVICES TO THE COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
A HUMAN AND YOU DID GREAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MARIEKE A LATIN I'M THE DIRECTOR
FOR THE SAN BERNADINO DEPARTMENT
OF CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES.
POVERTY IN SAMBOR MEDINA WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN THE
STATE AVERAGE TWENTY SIX PARTS
SCENT OF THE CHILDREN IN THE
COUNTY ARE LIVING IN POVERTY.
AND SINGLE PARENT HOUSEHOLDS ON
FATHER'S NOT PRESENT THIS
INCREASES TO FORTY FOUR PERCENT
AND HAS NOT DECREASED OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS. THESE OTHER
FAMILIES THAT NEED OUR SERVICES
TO ESTABLISH AND COLLECT
CONSISTENT AND RELIABLE CHILD
SUPPORT.
WHAT WE ARE VERY COST EFFECTIVE
COLLECTING FOUR DOLLARS AND
SIXTY THREE CENTS FOR EVERY
DOLLAR SPENT WE ARE UNABLE TO
REACH ALL OF OUR CUSTOMERS?
WE HAVE THE LOWEST ALLOCATION BY
CASE YET THE SECOND LARGEST
CASELOAD IN THE STATE.
I CASE WORKERS UNABLE TO
PROACTIVELY WORK CASES BY
WORKING PROACTIVELY WITH ARE
NONCUSTODIAL PARENTS WE CAN HELP
THEM TO REMOVE BARRIERS AND GET
THEM ON THE PATH.
TO PAY THEIR CHILD SUPPORT
CONSISTENTLY.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WILL ALLOW
SANDRA DINO TO PROVIDE THE SAME
SERVICE TO OUR FAMILIES AS IN
OTHER COUNTIES.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE THE
STEPS NECESSARY TO ENGAGE OUR
CUSTOMERS EARLY ON PARTNER WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
HOLISTICALLY HELP OUR CUSTOMERS.
AND CONDUCT OUT REACHING
COMMUNITIES WHERE WE DO NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE A PRESENCE.
THIS PROACTIVE APPROACH WILL
ENSURE EVERY CHILD GETS THE
SERVICE AND SUPPORT THEY NEED
AND ULTIMATELY SHIFT THE CYCLE
OF POVERTY IN THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE SERVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
TERRY HARDY PORTER TO SACRAMENTO
COUNTY TO A CHILD SUPPORT
DIRECTOR AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THIS AND YOU'VE HEARD A LOT OF
WHY I AM IN SUPPORT OF THAT. BUT
I'LL TELL YOU JUST A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN OUR CASELOAD IS
BASICALLY STAYED THE SAME ABOUT
A THREE PERCENT CHAINS DECREASE
OUR FUNDING HAS BEEN FLAT.
R. F. T. E. IS AUTHORIZED
LEFTIES HAVE DECREASED BY TWENTY
SEVEN PERCENT.
YOU CANNOT EFFECTIVELY MANAGE A
CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM WHICH IS
ANTI POVERTY ANTI CHILD POVERTY.
WITH A TWENTY SEVEN PERCENT
DECREASE IN STAFFING RESOURCES
WE KNOW THAT THE ECONOMY IS
CHANGING. OUR CASELOAD IS
CHANGING WE'RE LOOKING FOR
FAMILIES AND PARENTS WHO ARE
WORKING IN THE GIG ECONOMY WE'RE
LOOKING FOR PARENTS WHO ARE
WORKING SHORT TERM CONTRACT
WORK.
THAT TAKES HUMAN RESOURCES IN
OUR COUNTY.
EIGHTY PLUS PERCENT OF OUR CASE
LOAD IS CURRENTLY ASSISTED OR
FORMALLY ASSISTANT THEY ARE THE
HARDEST TO SERVE. AND THAT TAKES
HUMAN RESOURCES
WITH THE TWENTY SEVEN PERCENT
DECREASE IN F. T. E.'S WE ARE
UNABLE TO ACTUALLY SERVE THOSE
FAMILIES WHO ARE IN THE MOST
NEED.
I AM URGING YOU.
PORT.
I HAD THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DON
MARRON ON THE TRACTOR GLENN
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES.
IN GOING COUNTY WE STRIVE TO
MAINTAIN OUR FISH SINCE HE'S BE
COST EFFECTIVE FOR EVERY DOLLAR
SPENT IN OUR PROGRAM WE BRING IN
OVER FOUR DOLLARS.
WE AND DURING THE TIME WE
MAINTAIN PERFORMANCE WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME WE HAVE LOST FORTY
PERCENT OF OUR STAFF.
AND THAT HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
LOSE MORE IN THE COMING YEARS.
THE PARTICIPANTS WE CURRENTLY
SERVE COME FROM ALL WALKS OF
LIFE.
SOME WORK IN THE GAG IN THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY.
THERE UNBANKED THEY HAVE
LANGUAGE BARRIERS.
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND HAVE DIFFICULTY
NAVIGATING THE LEGAL SYSTEM.
WITHOUT THE CASEWORKER
INTERVENTION.
AND THE RICH RESOURCES TO DO
THEIR JOB THE LEVEL OF SERVICE
COULD BE AFFECTED WHICH WOULD
RESULT IN A NEGATIVE IMPACT TO
OUR FAMILIES.
CURRENTLY SEVENTY NINE PERCENT
OF OUR CASELOAD IS NEVER
INFORMALLY ASSISTANT.
THE COLLECTIONS WE MAKE ON
BEHALF OF THESE CASES GO
DIRECTLY TO THE FAMILIES.
WITHOUT THE CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES BASIC NEEDS LIKE FOOD
SHELTER AND CLOTHING WILL NOT BE
MET. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
THANK HIM.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SURE MORE
THEY'LL TRY HO THE DIRECTOR OF
THE MERCED MARIPOSA REGIONAL
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES.
WITH OVER TWENTY PERCENT OF OUR
RESIDENTS LIVING IN POVERTY
MERCED COUNTY IS OFTEN REFERRED
TO AS THE CENTER OF POVERTY.
TWENTY SEVEN PERCENT OF THE
CHILDREN ARE OUR COMMUNITY LIVE
IN POVERTY.
AS A RURAL COUNTY STILL
RECOVERING FROM THE RECENT
RECESSION. THE RESIDENTS OF
MERCED COUNTY RELY UPON THE
COLLECTIONS OBTAINED BY OUR
DEPARTMENT TO CREATE STABLE
HOMES FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
AS A POVERTY PREVENTION TOOL AS
YOU HEARD BY MY COLLEAGUES
MERCED COUNTY DISTRIBUTES EIGHTY
FIVE PERCENT OF THE COLLECTIONS
DIRECTLY FAMILIES. THESE DIRECT
DOLLARS ENABLE SELF SUFFICIENCY
AND PROVIDE AN IMMEDIATE STATE
RETURN ON INVESTMENT BY COST
AVOIDANCE A PROFESSION.
TANGIBLE PUBLIC SERVICES AS WELL
AS RECRUITMENT OF PUBLIC
SERVICES ADOPT PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
DOLLARS EXPENDED.
INVESTMENT IN OUR PROGRAM RESULT
IN IMMEDIATE FEDERAL DOLLAR
CONTRIBUTION OF TWO DOLLARS FOR
EVERY DOLLAR CONTRIBUTED TO WORK
BY OUR STATE.
OUR CONTINUED FLAT FUNDING
LIMITS MERCED'S ABILITY TO
ACTIVELY WORK THE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND PLUS CASES OUR
CASELOAD.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS SEEN A FORTY
SIX PERCENT DECREASE IN STAFFING
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND TWO. AT
OUR LOCAL COLLECTIONS HAVE BEEN
DECLINING RESULTING IN A LOSS OF
MILLIONS TO OUR CUSTOMERS.
AND INVESTMENT IN OUR PROGRAM IS
NOT ONLY AN INVESTMENT FOR THE
STATE BUT ALSO FOR THE CAN
COMMUNITY WE SERVE. THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU
MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S CHUCK
APOLOGIES OUT 12-1 WITH THE
STANISLAUS DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES.
THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT IN THE
PROGRAM WILL BE MORE THAN THREE
FOLD A STANISLAUS GENERATED
THREE DOLLARS AND EIGHTY CENTS
FOR EVERY DOLLAR SPENT ON THE
PROGRAM I SHARE. NOT RECEIVING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WOULD MEAN
THE LOSS OF POTENTIAL
COLLECTIONS AND LONGER WAIT
TIMES FOR SERVICES FOR FAMILIES
WHO RELY ON CHILD SUPPORT AS A
REAL INCOME.
AND ALSO WOULD RESULT IN
UNREALIZED RECRUITMENT BACK TO
THE STATE FEDERAL AND COUNTY
AGENCIES.
FOR SOME FAMILIES IN OUR CASE
LOAD THE ADDITIONAL CHILD
SUPPORT MEANS HEALTHIER FOOD ON
THE TABLE. AND FOR OTHERS IT HAS
BECOME THE SAVINGS THEY NEEDED
FOR A CHILD'S COLLEGE EDUCATION
HAVING WILL WORK MULTIPLE JOBS
TO RAISE THE CHILD. FOR OTHERS
IT'S MEDICAL SUPPORT THAT THEY
WOULD OTHERWISE NOT HAVE.
IN ALL ASPECTS AND I COUNTY
WHERE APPROXIMATELY ONE FOURTH
OF CHILDREN LIVE BELOW THE
POVERTY LEVEL CHILD SUPPORT
PROVIDE SOME FINANCIAL
STABILITY.
THE RECRUITMENT IS EQUALLY
IMPORTANT HELPING OFFSET COSTS
AND REDUCING RELIANCE ON ALREADY
TIGHT FUNDING FOR OTHER PROGRAMS
WHILE ENABLING CHILD SUPPORT TO
BE RECOGNIZED AND EFFECTIVE
PARTNER. IN THE SAFETY NET AND
POVERTY PREVENTION NETWORK OF
AGENCIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
BUT AFTERNOON DAVID OVER
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES WE SERVE OVER EIGHTY
THREE THOUSAND CASES ARGUABLY
SHOULD BE PROBABLY DOUBLE THAT.
OF THE EMPHASIS OF THIS
RECRUITMENT EVER THIS REQUEST IS
TO BRING.
COUNTIES IN THE LOWER FUNDED UP
TO BE MORE ADEQUATELY FUNDED
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE PERFORMANCE
OF THOSE COUNTIES THEY PERFORM
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER THAN US AND
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO DELIVER
THE SAME SERVICE AS POSSIBLE SO
I ECHO THE COMMENTS THE REST AND
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT. THIS MONTH
OFFERED THINK THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
CHAVEZ I'M THE DIRECTOR OF KERN
COUNTY CHILD SUPPORT.
I'M HERE TO REPRESENT THE
CHILDREN OF THAT WE SERVE
CURRENT POVERTY RATE IS TWENTY
PERCENT TWENTY TWO PERCENT WITH
TWENTY SIX AND A HALF PERCENT OF
OUR CHILDREN LIVING IN POVERTY.
CURRENTS CURRENTLY CASELOAD
CONSIST OF FIFTY ONE THOUSAND
CASES.
OF THESE CHILDREN IN OUR CASES
TWENTY NINE PERCENT ARE
CURRENTLY RECEIVING ASSISTANCE
FIFTY FIVE REFORM OF THE SYSTEM
AND SEVENTEEN PERCENT ARE NEVER
ASSISTED. CURRENT RETURN ON
INVESTMENT IS THREE DOLLARS AND
EIGHTY NINE CENTS
IN FISCAL YEAR SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
A TOTAL OF OVER FIVE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS WAS RETURNED TO
THE STATE GENERAL FUND FROM OUR
COLLECTIONS.
STAFFING LEVELS FROM TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE TO PRESENT
HAVE DECREASED THIRTY TWO
PERCENT. THIS HAS AFFECTED THE
LEVEL OF SERVICE WE CAN PROVIDE
TO OUR FAMILIES WHO LIVE IN
OUTLYING AREAS OF KERN.
KERN IS VERY LARGE AND SPREAD
OUT.
CHILDREN A MATTER WHERE THEY
LIVE SHOULD BE ABLE TO RELY AND
CONSISTENT MONTHLY CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS EVERY DOLLAR INVESTED
INVESTED MAKES A DIFFERENCE IN
THE LIFE OF A CHILD. THIS
REQUEST WILL ALLOW KERN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND THE NET
AND HELP MORE FAMILIES BECOME
SELF SUFFICIENT. OTHER STREAMING
OFF OF PUBLIC ASSISTANCE AN
INCREASE COLLABORATION WITH BOTH
PARENTS FOR THE SUCCESS OF THEIR
CHILDREN WHICH IN THE END HOUSE
TO BUILD A BETTER COMMUNITY AND
A BETTER STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LISA
DO AGAIN I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
NORTH COAST REGIONAL DEPARTMENT
OF CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES. AND
THAT WOULD BE HUMBOLDT AND
TRINITY COUNTIES.
I'M HERE TODAY AS AN ADEQUATELY
FUNDED COUNTY SUPPORTING MY
COLLEAGUES REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDS INTO OUR
PROGRAM.
AS AN ADEQUATELY FUNDED COUNTY
THE WRITINGS ON THE WALL THAT
THE.
IT WILL ONLY BE A MATTER OF
TIME BEFORE WE AS WELL ARE UNDER
FUNDED.
WE RIGHT NOW ARE IN A POSITION
TO PROVIDE INNOVATIVE SERVICES
TO HELP BUOY OUR SISTER
COUNTIES.
WE HAVE SHARED SERVICES IN CALL
CENTERS ACROSS THE STATE WE
OFFER WORKERS COMP A COLLECTION
SERVICE SAYS. OF WE HAVE
REGIONALIZED ALL OF THESE THINGS
HAVE HELPED TO A SMALL DEGREE.
BUT THERE'S NO SILVER BULLET OUR
PROGRAM NEEDS AN INFUSION OF
MONEY SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A
CONVERSATION. TO AUTUMN ACTUALLY
HAVE A METHODOLOGY THAT DOESN'T
CREATE WINNERS AND LOSERS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON DON SIMONE I'M
THE PRESIDENT THE CHILD SUPPORT
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. OUT WE ARE HAPPY TO
HAVE AS OUR MEMBERS ALL FORTY
NINE OF THE LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
DIRECTORS AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
.
YOU MENTIONED SOME THINGS
EARLIER THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
ECHO YOU ASKED FIRST ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THIS WORK
GROUP AND YOU CAN SEE WE HAVE
QUITE A NUMBER OF A DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS INVOLVED WHICH IS
GREAT. WE ARE.
WE'VE HAD ONE MEETING THREE
MORE AS YOU MENTIONED WE ARE
FOCUSED ON.
I A AS I'VE HEARD CALLED THE A
PATCH OR SOME MONEY INTO THE
SYSTEM NOW NEW FUNDING WHAT
WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE WERE ALSO
DISCUSSING METHODOLOGY. WE'RE
LOOKING AT DELIVERABLES A RETURN
ON INVESTMENT.
AS WELL AS A MULTI YEAR ROLE IN
AND FINALLY A COMMITMENT LONG
TERM TO LOOK AT OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES
IN THE PROGRAM ITSELF. SO AGAIN
I I THINK THAT THERE IS A VERY
STRONG COMMITMENT FOR THIS PAT
AND TO WORK TOWARDS A.
UNANSWERED SO THAT WE CAN GET
SOME FUN INTO PROGRAM THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR.
CHAIRMAN A MEMBER SPOILER
SHUDDER AND THREE.
HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY STANISLAUS
COUNTY.
KERN MERCED AND FRESNO COUNTY
THINKING CONCERT.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS FOR
ANY QUESTIONS THAT WE MAY HAVE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO JUST A
COMMENT I KNOW.
HOW CRITICAL IT IS I'M A LA
COUNTY AND I HEAR THE THE MAJOR
PROBLEMS THAT WE'RE HAVING IN?
IN THAT AREA AND IT'S A HUGE
COUNTY AND.
WE HAVE A HUGE POPULATION OF.
OF OF KIDS THAT NEED THE
SUPPORTS I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS UP AND HOPEFULLY
WE CAN GET SOME FUNDING FOR.
FOR FOR YOU SO THAT WE CAN NOW
MOVE THE PROCESS ALONG AND. I
CAN'T BELIEVE IT'S BEEN SINCE
THE NINETIES THAT YOU'VE GOTTEN
AN INCREASE AND I KNOW HOW
DIFFICULT IT MIGHT BE SO THANK
YOU FOR A FOR THE WORK AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN.
CONTINUE PARTICIPATING IN THOSE
WORK GROUPS SO THAT WE ARE
INFORMED ABOUT WHAT THE PROGRESS
IF YOU COULD SEND THIS
INFORMATION.
I'D TO MY OFFICE OR TOOL I'M
REQUESTING A FOR MYSELF BUT I AM
I. SURE THAT THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE WOULD ALSO RECALL LIKE
TO GET THE INFORMATION SO THAT
WE CAN KEEP UP WITH IT AND WE
DON'T. HAVE TO COME BACK AGAIN
AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT Y'ALL
WERE DOING YOU KNOW THIS LAST
FEW MONTHS OR APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU.
I WAS HOPING THE COUNTIES THAT
MADE THE REQUEST CAN YOU TELL US
A BIT MORE ABOUT THE INVESTMENTS
THE COUNTIES WOULD MAKE. GIFT
GIVEN THE REQUESTED DOLLARS AND
THEN I BELIEVE YOU HAD MENTIONED
SOME OF THE DELIVERABLES.
IN TERMS OF INCREASES BUT WAS
WONDERING.
HOW WE WOULD BE ABLE TO ENFORCE
THAT IF?
WE SET THOSE GOALS.
WELL.
.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION THE
LARGEST.
PRODUCER OF RESULTS FOR OUR FOR
OUR COUNTIES. WILL BE CASE
WORKERS AND THAT'S THE STAFFING
AS YOU HEARD FROM MANY MY
COLLEAGUES HAS. REALLY BEEN THE
ISSUE THAT HAS.
BROUGHT US TO THE REALLY TOOK
PLACE WE ARE TODAY.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT A MAJORITY OF
THE FUNDING THAT WERE REQUESTED
IT IT WILL GO FOR IT CASE
WORKERS HOWEVER.
THERE'S ALSO OTHER SERVICES THAT
ARE FOURTEEN COUNTIES HAVE. HAD
TO CUT BACK OR CURTAIL BECAUSE
OF THE STAFFING ISSUES ONE OF
THOSE IS OUTREACH. OUTREACH
SERVICES PROGRAM AWARENESS
SERVICES.
I'M. NOT TAKE MYSELF FROM FOR
EXAMPLE IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
SOUTHERN PART OF THE COUNTY IS
ONE OF THE FASTEST GROWING PARTS
OF THE STATE HOWEVER WE DON'T
HAVE A PRESENCE THERE.
SO I HAVE BY NO I FAMILIES. THAT
DON'T KNOW THAT THEIR CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES AVAILABLE AND
MAYBE THEY LIKE TO PARTAKE OF IT
BUT THEY DON'T KNOW THAT WE'RE
HERE BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A
PRESENCE.
YOU KNOW I'D LIKE TO HAVE A
PRESENCE ON THE PART OF THE
COUNTY. I KNOW THAT SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
SPECIAL PROGRAM.
THAT HELP FAMILIES.
.
WITH MAYBE MENTAL HEALTH OR DRUG
ADDICTION ISSUES.
GET OVER THOSE ISSUES SO THAT
THE WAY THEY CAN BE A SOLID PART
OF THEIR CHILD'S LIFE AND ALSO A
PROVIDE THAT FINANCIAL SUPPORT.
COME WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE
ARE.
MANY OTHER AVENUES IN TERMS WE'D
LIKE TO PROVIDE EXTENDED HOURS
WE'D LIKE TO PROVIDE MOBILE
SERVICES. YOU LIKE IT'S A COUNTY
LIKE SANDRA DINO OR KERN COUNTY
THAT SO LARGE.
ITS TOUGH FOR PEOPLE TO YOU
KNOW DRIVE FROM ONE PART OF THE
COUNTY TO BAKERSFIELD OR TO
SALMON MEDINA. SAID THEY'D LIKE
TO HAVE A MOBILE SERVICE
AVAILABLE AVAILABILITY SO THAT
WAY THEY CAN REACH EVERYBODY WHO
NEEDS HELP SUPPORT SERVICES.
SO THAT'S IN TERMS OF THE. WHAT
WE? ARE THINKING IN WE NEED TO
DO WITH THE MONEY. IN TERMS OF
OUTPUTS WE THINK THAT.
THERE'S A LOT OF.
THINK THERE'S GREAT POTENTIAL.
IN US BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE
CUSTOMER SERVICES THAT.
SO FAR WE HAVEN'T BEEN WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO DO WE WOULD
LIKE TO DO. WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE CASES THAT WE HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO GET TO.
ON JUST BECAUSE SO MANY CASES
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT.
THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE NOT AMENABLE
TO THE AUTOMATED SERVICES
AVAILABLE WITHIN THE CHILD
SUPPORT ENFORCEMENT SYSTEM.
IN ORDER TO OPEN A CASE IS
SOMETIMES IT TAKES.
A LOT OF WORK DETECTIVE WORK I
WOULD SAY TO FIND AND TO FIND
INCOME ORDER FIND AN EMPLOYER.
YOU NEED A PERSON IN ORDER TO DO
THAT YOU NEED A PERSON TO
ANALYZE THOSE RESULTS.
WE'D LIKE TO LOOK IT UP
REDUCING THE TIME IT TAKES FROM
WHEN YOU OPEN THE CASE TO WHEN
YOU ACTUALLY GET A PAYMENT.
RIGHT NOW I THINK THE STATE WIDE
AVERAGES OVER TWO HUNDRED DAYS.
COULD YOU IMAGINE IF YOU HAD TO
GO IN AND YOU REQUESTED
SERVICES.
YOU DON'T GET ANYTHING BACK FOR
NEAR FROM MORE THAN HALF A YEAR.
SOME.
THAT'S REALLY. UP A TERRIBLE
STAND ON OUR PROGRAM WE WANT TO
REDUCE THAT AND WE THINK WITH
ADDITIONAL CASEWORKERS. WE'D BE
ABLE TO DO THAT.
AND AND OF COURSE THE OTHER
THING THAT WE THINK THAT WE
COULD DO TREMENDOUSLY WITH THE
MONEY IS TO INCREASE. ADDITIONAL
COLLECTIONS.
THAT ARE FOURTEEN COUNTIES COULD
PRODUCE WE ALSO THINK THAT THAT
WOULD HAVE.
AND ADDITIONAL EFFORT BECAUSE OF
FILE WERE ABLE TO BRING HIM THE
MONEY AND AND WE'RE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF INNOVATIVE
SERVICES.
WE CAN ALSO PROVIDE THOSE BEST
PRACTICES
TO ARE COLLEAGUES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. TO RETHINK THAT THERE MAY
ALSO BE AN ABILITY TO INCREASE
COLLECTIONS STATEWIDE AS WELL.
I WANTED TO.
.
UNDERSTAND A BIT MORE FOR CAN
FROM THE DEPARTMENT WHY WERE IN
THIS STAGE I. BELIEVE IT'S OF
BUDGETING METHODOLOGY AND THAT
SPACE ALLOCATION THAT'S JUST
STATUTORILY FROM MANY YEARS AGO.
AND I'M.
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IF THERE
WAS ANY DISCUSSION ABOUT IT
SEEMS LIKE WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO
MOVE THE.
UP TO SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY
DOLLARS
WAS THERE ANY.
DISCUSSION ABOUT DISPLACING
DOLLARS FROM COUNTIES WHO ARE
ABOVE THAT.
I ONLY ASK.
AND DO BELIEVE THAT. ULTIMATELY
WE'RE GOING TO WANT TO HAVE A
HOLD HARMLESS POLICY BUT WANTED
TO.
UNDERSTAND IF THOSE DISCUSSIONS
DID HAPPEN.
SURE I MISTER.
THERE HAVE BEEN SEVERAL.
DISCUSSIONS SINCE THE PROGRAM.
.
WAS REFORMED.
AROUND BUDGET ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGY I THINK SOME OF THE
CURRENT.
DISPARITY AND COSTS AMONG THE LC
ESSAYS ARE FUNDING AMONG THE
ALSO SAY'S HAS TO DO WITH.
HISTORICAL FUNDING FORMULAS
UNDER THE DA'S OFFICES COUNTIES
COULD CONTRIBUTE VARYING LEVELS
OF COUNTY SHARES AND TO ANSWER
THOSE COUNTIES. THAT INVESTED
MORE IN THEIR CHILD'S FOR
PROGRAMS AND TO DO BETTER THAN
THOSE WHO INVEST IT LASTS.
AND THERE'S ALSO FOR A TWO YEAR
PERIOD SOMETHING HALL THE
THIRTEEN POINT SIX PERCENT
FUNDING FORMULA.
THAT BASICALLY GAVE THE COUNTIES
AND ALLOCATION BASED ON THIRTEEN
POINT SIX PERCENT OF THEIR
COLLECTIONS.
SAVE YOUR.
I COUNTY WITH SAY MORE AFFLUENT
CASE LADY TEND TO HAVE HIGHER
ALLOCATION THOSE ARE LESS
AFFLUENT HAVE LOWER ALLOCATIONS.
THAT FUNDING FOR MILLET WAS
SUSPENDED TWO THOUSAND THREE
FORM BECAUSE IT WAS CREATING
SUCH DISPARITIES AMONG THE
COUNTIES.
AND IT JUST DIDN'T WORK.
THE DEPARTMENT AS CONVENED A
NUMBER OF WORK GROUPS TO TALK
ABOUT DIFFERENT ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGIES.
SAM YOU KNOW I WOULD SAY THAT
THOSE GROUPS THAT STRUGGLE TO
REACH CONSENSUS SO THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY YOU DIDN'T SEE
ANY BUDGET METHODOLOGY PUT
PLACE.
AND THEN THERE IS THE ISSUE
THAT YOU POINTED TO THAT IF
THERE WASN'T THE IF THERE WAS AN
NEW FUNDING INTRODUCED INTO THE
SYSTEM.
AND YOU HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS
RANDY ALLOCATIONS YOU WOULD HAVE
THOSE WINNERS AND LOSERS
DISCUSSIONS.
AND I THINK THE CONCERN IS IS
THAT WOULD.
KICK CRATE GROSS DISRUPTIONS
AMONG THE SYSTEM.
SO IF YOU'RE A COUNTY WHO'S MORE
ADEQUATELY FUNDED. AND YOU
TRANSFER YOU KNOW FUNDING TO AN
UNDERFUNDED COUNTY WHAT IS THAT
DUE TO YOUR IN HOUSE STAFFING
AND YOUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
SERVICES.
ESPECIALLY IN A FIVE FUNDING
SCENARIO WHERE COAL IS WILL
CONTINUE TO EAT AWAY AT YOUR
PROGRAM FUNDING.
EVENTUALLY WHERE DOES IT BUT
THOSE COUNTIES WHO ARE
ADEQUATELY FUNDED EVENTUALLY GET
TO THE POINT WHERE THEY'LL BE
UNDER FUNDED THEMSELVES.
SO I THINK IN OTHER DEPARTMENTS
REALLY BEEN FOCUSED ON A MORE
HOLISTIC SOLUTION. TROY ADDRESS
FUNDING ISSUES.
YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW FOR THE PROGRAM AS A
WHOLE AND ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY
THAT WORKS FOR ALL THE COUNTIES.
I SAW OFFERING SUMMER.
FOR THE FOURTEEN COUNTIES.
WE USE THE SIX HUNDRED THIRTY
DOLLARS COST PER CASE
METHODOLOGY BECAUSE IT WAS AN
OBJECTIVE WAY.
TO TO SORT OF FIGURE OUT A
SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM HOWEVER
FOR THE FOURTEEN I WOULD SAY
THAT WE'RE VERY FLEXIBLE. IN
TERMS OF WHAT THE METHODOLOGY.
SHOULD BE AND COULD BE SO.
IN.
I THINK THERE'S MANY WAYS. THAT
THAT METHODOLOGY COULD BE
CALCULATED.
COST PER CASES ONE AND COST PER
FTE IS ANOTHER BUT I JUST WANTED
TO LET YOU ALL KNOW THAT WERE
VERY FLEXIBLE. IN TERMS OF HOW
THAT METHODOLOGY CANON SHOULD
LOOK IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
OUR COMMITTEE IS GOING TO WANT
THOUGH LOOKING TO LOOK AT THIS
HOLISTIC.
RESULT AFTERWARDS AND WILL HOPE
THAT YOU INCLUDE US AFTER THE
COMPLETION OF THESE NEXT THREE
MEETINGS SO THAT WE CAN
DELIVERY.
WHO TRYING TO GET AN
UNDERSTANDING OF TIMING IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT YOU THINK WE WILL
BE AVAILABLE TO? COME TO SOME
RESOLUTION BEFORE MAY REVISE
OR IS THIS SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO NEED TO GO PAST THIS
FISCAL YEAR.
AND IT YOU KNOW I'M KIND OF AT
THE BEGINNING OF MY REMARKS INTO
THIS ISN'T AN ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSALS WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS. I WOULD
PROBABLY HAVE TO TURN TO OTHER
CSTA ARE ONE OF THE FOURTEEN
COUNTIES REALLY SPEAK TO. WHERE
THEY SEE THIS GOING?
SO OUR OUR.
CONVERSATIONS AFTER THE LAST
BUDGET. MEETING WORD THAT WE ARE
GOING TO TRY TO PRODUCE
SOMETHING.
TO BE INCLUDED IN THE MAY
REVISED BUDGET.
YES I GOT SOME CSK PRESENT.
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES SAID OUR
GOAL IS TO HAVETHESE THREE
MEETINGS THE FOLLOWING WEEK
RIGHT SOME I MEAN HAVE YOU SPEAK
INTO THE MIKE JUST SO THAT THOSE
WHO ARE NOT. PRESENT TODAY ARE.
SORT OF ON THAT. OUR GOAL IS TO
FINISH THESE THREE MEETINGS.
UP A WEEK FROM TO MORROW AND
THEN HAVE SOMETHING WRITTEN UP
THE FOLLOWING WEEK AND SUBMITTED
TO THE CONSULTANTS ARE ON MAY
SEVENTH. THANK YOU WE LOOK
FORWARD TO RECEIVING THAT UPDATE
AND SEEING.
MR JUST AND I SOUND LIKE A
BROKEN RECORD.
THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS
AT SOME POINT CAN WE CONSIDER
THE HUMAN FACTOR IN THIS I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU KNOW THE
MEETINGS ARE IMPORTANT ALL OF
THAT. BY THAT IT'S REAL LIVES
THERE WERE AFFECTING HERE AND
THAT THERE IS FOR ME THAT'S
URGENCY. AYE AS INDICATED BY BY.
YOU KNOW THE TESTIMONY HOWEVER
IT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE THAT
SOMETIMES AND SOMEONE MAKE SURE
THAT WE.
WHEN WE SUBMIT THIS IS NOT JUST
SOME LINE ITEM THIS IS REAL KIDS
THAT ARE BEING EFFECTIVE
AFFECTED ONE WAY OR THE OTHER
WILL. YOU KNOW WHETHER IT WOULD
BE WITH THE MONEY OR THE LACK
THEREOF SO IF WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT THAT IS ALSO. INTERJECTED
IN THE LATTER AND.
THAT SENT TO OF BEFORE THE MAY
REVISE.
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT WE WILL
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND CONCLUDE
TODAY'S SOMEONE HEARING THANK
YOU ALL FOR COMING HERE